Okay.
Hey D,
everybody,
this episode of the podcast is brought to you by Squarespace.
Squarespace is the all in one platform that makes it fast and easy to create
your own professional website.
And I mean really professional,
excellent,
outstanding website as if it was designed by like some wizard html expert.
Squarespace has beautiful designs for you to start with all style options,
uh,
that you need to create a unique website for you and your business.
A simple drag and drop interface and the offer 24 seven support,
which I doubt you'll need.
It really works excellent.
If you can attach pictures to an email or to a word document.
And if you know your way around a computer,
drag and drop,
super easy to do and it works on everything.
It'll work on iPhones,
androids,
windows,
Linux,
really,
uh,
like I can't,
I can't say enough about Squarespace.
I have a ton of friends that use it and I'm actually starting up a blog that
I'll be using Squarespace to design the website.
So I'm going to build it myself.
Uh,
Squarespace also has a logo creator where you can create a clean,
simple logo designed for yourself in minutes.
And every design automatically includes a unique mobile experience.
It matches the overall style of your websites,
or your content will look great on every device,
every time.
For a free trial and 10% off your first purchase,
go to squarespace.com and enter the code word Joe.
That's squarespace.com.
Enter the code word Joe for a free trial and 10% off your first purchase.
Squarespace.
A better web starts with your website.
That's how every copy ends.
I would suggest they remove that,
but they make me say it.
Don't make me,
but I don't want to be rude.
Tell them that their idea sucks,
but they're fucking website's awesome.
squarespace.com use the code where Joe.
Uh,
we've also been sponsored by legal zoom and legal zoom has an a plus from the
better business bureau.
You can't get any better than that.
I love it.
I love that a legal zoom is a service that allows you to do things that you
would normally have to go to an attorney's office and make an appointment and
wait in line to all that nonsense and you know,
go out of your way to drive across town.
You can do a lot of shit in your home easily.
Things like form an LLC,
form an s corporation,
trademark real estate documents.
Uh,
you can,
uh,
you can make a will,
a personalized will,
power of attorney and living trusts,
all that kind of shit.
You can do all of that through legal zoom.com and it's very easy to do.
Legal Zoom was developed by some of the best legal minds in the country
according to them.
You know,
I'm sure there's like a debate.
The other legal minds weren't involved like bullshit.
I'm the best anyway.
Excellent legal minds.
Like I said,
a plus from the better business bureau.
Uh,
we've used it.
Um,
Brian used it to form death squad.
Dot TV.
Uh,
we use it originally to form on it.com,
uh,
the LLC for on it.
So very easy to do.
And for special savings,
be sure to enter Rogan in the referral box at checkout.
Protect your family,
protect your future at legal zoom.
What does it a gun?
The fuck does that mean?
Is it a time machine?
What are you saying?
Legal Zoom was developed by top attorneys to provide self help services at your
specific direction.
But they are not a legal firm.
They're not a law firm.
But what they can do is they can contact you,
uh,
put you in contact with a third party independent attorney.
So if you're in the middle of filling out the documents and you're like,
oh my God,
I've done this wrong,
I'm probably going to get sued or go to jail,
they'll hook you up.
Don't worry about it.
Easy,
easy peasy.
Again,
go to legalzoom.com enter the code word again,
r o g a n in the referral box at checkout and save yourself some cash.
Legal Zoom.
Can't recommend them enough.
And we're also brought to you last but not least by on at.com.
That is o and n I t what is on it?
The idea of on it,
even the,
the name on it,
the idea is that get on it,
get your shit together on it is what we call a human optimization website.
We sell the very best in strength and conditioning equipment.
Things like kettlebells,
steel maces,
steel clubs,
things that provide what they call functional fitness,
functional strength and what does that mean?
Functional strength?
Functional fitness means like things that when you,
when you work out,
it could directly translate to real world applications like simple stuff like
moving a couch,
do a lot of kettle bells,
lift a lot of weights,
get your body strong and you'll be able to pick shit up and move it around
better.
It sounds so simple,
but that's a good thing to have.
It's a good,
it's a good quality to have to have a strong body.
It's essentially like if life was a race and you were at,
you were in a car and you could just do things to your race car to make it
stronger and faster and handle better.
Wouldn't you do that?
Of course.
Will,
your body essentially is your vehicle for getting through this life and you can
improve it,
you can improve it with nutrition,
you can improve it with supplementation and you can certainly improve it with
strength and conditioning exercises.
And we sell the very best shit when it comes to things like weight vests and
medicine balls.
And,
um,
we even have videos.
Uh,
I keep recommending it but I can't recommend it enough cause it's really
excellent.
The Keith Webber,
extreme Kettlebell Cardio series.
What's great about those is Keith's a stud,
he's in awesome shape and he does the exercise while you do them.
So you just follow along with him and you know,
when someone's in really good shape and you're doing it along with them,
you,
you know,
you want to work on hard,
it,
it makes you motivated.
So,
uh,
go there.
We actually will actually also having a 72 hour sale right now.
As of right now,
the time is one 18 on September the second and a,
there's two days,
22 hours,
41 minutes and 12 seconds.
You can get 15% off everything using the code.
September seven two that September seven two for the 72 hour sale.
CEP,
s e p seven two,
I shouldn't that shouldn't say September s e p seven too.
So save yourself some money,
15% off everything.
All right,
you're freaks.
Go to on it.
O n n I t and if you're listening to this,
after that time,
use the codeword Rogan and you will save 10% off any and all supplements.
Uh,
we've got a lot of stuff at on it that has not been there before.
If you haven't been there in awhile.
We're constantly adding new things that we find online,
including we have a new version of t plus that also comes with some new studies
that we did,
um,
that are published on the website.
All the stuff that we have,
whether it's a Alpha brain or shroom tech,
everything is described in the greatest detail.
We can't,
along with the research,
all the research papers with reference pertaining to the individual ingredients
in any of the supplements.
And uh,
you can get it all at Onnit.
O.
N.
N I.
T.
All right,
that's it.
Boom.
Done.
Sam Harris.
Is here.
Why fuck around.
Cue The music.
Jamie,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Try by day Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
My friend Sam Harris,
author,
awesome dude martial artist,
and a author of waking up a guy to spirituality without religion.
I told you,
I first found out about you from a,
my friend Joe Silva,
who's the matchmaker,
uh,
for the UFC who gave me your book.
He gave me a letter to a Christian nation,
uh,
many,
many years ago.
Like when did,
when did you post that post?
Eight,
2006.
Six.
Yeah.
He gave it to me like around then he's like,
I gotta read this.
It's awesome.
And I did.
And,
uh,
look,
we're pals.
Cool.
Here we go.
Yeah,
that's great.
And your new book,
Waking Up,
a guide to spirituality without religion.
Well,
that's impossible.
So your book is nonsense,
right?
Cause I need God in your life.
I'm running into that.
Well,
no,
actually I'm running to the other side of that where spirituality makes no sense
unless you believe in religion.
That's it.
But what,
what is,
there's no such thing as a spirit.
So,
uh,
you know,
why,
why would you,
why would you want to endorse something called spirituality?
That's a kind of,
uh,
that's uh,
that's fair,
isn't it?
Like what is a spirit,
I mean,
don't,
don't you have to have faith in something too,
to sort of just the idea of a spirit if you're gonna if you're going to talk
about spirituality or a spirit.
Like what are you really talking about?
Like,
yeah,
well I'm definitely not talking about a spirit or a soul or anything that can
float off the brain at death.
And I think spirituality is one of these words that we just have to reclaim
because there's really not an English equivalent for,
for this area of inquiry.
Is that if you want to take seriously the,
um,
what one question can I pull these off?
Cause I'm Jack.
Um,
cool.
You have one item,
like it's kind of distorted sound.
Oh really?
Yeah,
it could be.
My brain could be the,
but it's a lot better with these office.
So maybe God talking to you here.
Uh,
you're,
you're blocking them out as fast as they've gotten these.
If God needs these,
we know he's losing,
his powers are limited.
I'll take these off too and we'll leave it up to Jamie to find out whether or
not,
there we go.
Cool.
Um,
so I nearly as loud.
So,
uh,
yeah.
So,
so this is a big hangup for atheists and secularists and skeptics that this,
this idea that spirituality is a word that magic and superstition by FY debt by
definition and by its etymology,
cause it's,
it goes back to the,
the uh,
the Latin spirit to which comes from the Greek pneuma meaning breath and it says
idea that the spirit is,
is you're asserting some kind of dualism.
This and sort of the spirit that's internal to the body that is not produced by
the body,
that can leave the body at death.
And it's true that most people,
most of the time to have some quasi mystical,
spooky association with,
with the concept of spirituality.
And it's obviously linked up with all the stuff that people believe about
crystals and angels and all the other stuff that I don't want to be entangled
with.
But,
uh,
I just think they're there.
There's no word for,
if you're going to take seriously the,
the project of,
of becoming like Jesus,
whoever he was becoming,
someone who could,
they could actually love his neighbor as himself or,
um,
uh,
becoming like the Buddha or,
or,
or just a exploring the,
the,
the furthest reaches of positive human experience through meditation or
psychedelics or some other methodology that,
that,
that really perturbs consciousness,
there's no word for that endeavor and to,
and to call it Poe positive psychology or happiness or wellbeing.
Most people think they know what you mean when you use words like happiness and
wellbeing and love.
And,
and yet they have no idea how rarefied things can get if you,
if you take the right drug,
if you spend three months in silence doing nothing but meditate,
um,
it's just they're there.
It's a,
there are many layers to this thing.
And so I've tried to reclaim the term spirituality and um,
some guy,
some guy I was talking to recently on a podcast,
uh,
drew an analogy to the word evil,
which is another word that people are uncomfortable with because once we,
once we understand things like psychopathy and,
and other ways in which the,
the human mind can malfunction,
it seems that there's no rational basis to be talking about evil.
But I think we need the word evil.
I think we need to,
I think we need to reclaim the word evil for a secular,
rational conversation because we need a big word for,
for the,
the really the worst of human impulses and as well evil and good.
They don't seem to be dependent upon a religious belief.
I think evil is just what,
what affects a gang of people in a negative way or one individual,
you know,
poison a water supply.
Obviously that's an evil deed.
You're going to kill a bunch of people.
You're going to cause a bunch of pain that seems to make a,
at least some sense without religion and as does good,
like good and evil.
But actually not for evil.
The confidence in the use of the term evil has definitely a road at among
secular scientists types because it just,
just picture at once you understand what we're calling evil at the level of the
brain.
A,
once you,
once you find a gene for a dopamine receptor that correlates with psychopathy,
um,
uh,
or it's uh,
or a deficit of,
of uh,
central receptor,
then you,
then you begin to say,
well this is,
this is all just we're talking about biology,
we're talking about bad luck.
We're talking about a illness.
And then what,
what,
what does evil name in that case,
right?
Like what is it?
Psychopathy or like if you do something like say if,
uh,
someone,
I mean,
let,
let's,
let's talk about Israel and cause I don't like say if you are in Gaza and a,
a bomb is hit your apartment building and killed your family and you've made it
your,
your goal to kill as many Jews before they take you out.
Is that,
is that psychopathy,
is that evil?
What is that kind of retribution?
Is that,
I mean,
no,
no negative.
That's definitely a gray area.
Well,
I think with evil,
we want to reserve it for
those situations in which unprovoked,
yeah,
there's no story the person can tell that would seem to justify this to a
rational person.
You can't think,
well,
if I were in that person's shoes,
I would be doing the same thing you think this is,
this is a twisted kind of say to us and this person's taking pleasure in causing
suffering to other human beings,
uh,
unnecessarily.
Um,
in a way that I can't,
that doesn't resonate with me.
And,
and that's so that,
so the far end of the extremity where you have somebody who's,
you know,
whether you,
it's,
you know,
Hitler or,
or as a kind of a lower scale version of evil.
I think my favorite example of late has been,
um,
I actually one who I've,
I spoke about a fair amount on the topic of freewill,
which I think we'll get into is,
um,
Uday Hussein,
Saddam Hussein's Elvis son.
I mean,
this guy was just as pure a psychopath as you're ever going to find.
This is someone who when he would see a wedding and progress in Baghdad,
he and his thugs would descend and rape the bride and sometimes torture and kill
the bride and the theater to dogs.
Yeah,
I actually hadn't heard that yet.
This is just so when you hear that that's not the same thing as hearing that
somebodies house got bombed and their family died and then they become committed
to harming their aggressor is where people like their aggressors.
Right.
So,
um,
but yeah,
so I anyway,
did it just to back up and that point,
the,
um,
I feel like I'm embarrassed frankly by the term spirituality too.
I think it's,
it's,
it's just not,
um,
it's not a great word given its history.
And yet the only similar words that,
that,
that do a similar job or even spooky or something like mysticism,
um,
which is,
uh,
just even more
esoteric a term,
but I use the word contemplative to,
to name,
uh,
and in any practice that would be designed to,
discover what consciousness is like independent of just thinking about it.
Um,
so I think we need a new word right?
We need a new word for the thing is new equipment.
New Words is also a dead end to,
I hate Neil.
It just seems,
I hate it when some author comes forward with his,
his warrior that no one's ever heard of and he's hoping to foist it on the rest
of humanity is here's a new now and that you all have to choke on.
And it just also works when you,
whenever someone comes up with their own jargon like that,
it's usually a red flag as well.
And it's like,
what are you doing?
You need to sort of redefining the world.
I started to call like you coming up with your own jargon,
you know,
when people come up with their own terms for thin and they're numbered lists.
Yeah,
yeah.
Um,
but what is,
what is the purpose of this book or what is the,
the theme of this book,
If you know,
get past the word spirituality without religion being a good person,
without religion,
ethics,
morals.
Actually,
that was the,
the,
the thesis of my last book or the book before last,
the moral landscape where I talk about how we can understand strong claims of
right and wrong and good and evil in the context of science.
That you can have a strong conception of moral truth without believing that you
get your morality from God or from a holy book.
Um,
and so that's something I've,
I've argued for now.
This is a,
um,
this is really in my view,
a completion of the project.
I started with the end of faith where I,
you know,
I s I started by just noticing how divisive and unnecessary and,
and ultimately dangerous are,
are incompatible religious ideas are and how we need to have a secular
conversation about the problem there.
Um,
and then I went into,
so first I started talking about just how there's a,
there's a,
by definition a zero,
some conflict between science and religion because there's a zero,
some conflict between believing things for good reasons and believing things for
bad reasons.
Um,
and the people who are satisfied with bad reasons and willing to defend their
bad reasons with violence or with even with,
you know,
policy are hostile to the project of,
of,
of science.
Um,
but then once you,
so once you've criticized that problem and,
uh,
notice that these books can't possibly be infallible given all that we know
through science and notice that they can't possibly be infallible,
given that they're all mutually contradictory,
uh,
Christians and Muslims can't both be right.
Uh,
then you have to grapple with the fact that there's all these good things that
people think they're getting out of religion and they want to find some other
way to get those things.
And the first on the list is ethics and morality.
And so,
so the moral landscape was my argument that we can have a strong conception of
ethics without believing any bullshit.
And this is my effort to,
uh,
open up a conversation on the topic of spirituality,
which is the center of spirituality for me is the phenomenon of self
transcendence.
Just the fact that it's possible to lose your sense of self lose your sense of
being an ego,
lose your sense that you are,
you are a,
you know,
a rider on the horse of consciousness riding around inside your head.
Uh,
not,
not exactly identical to your physical body.
Most people don't feel that.
They simply are their bodies.
They feel like they have bodies and that their bodies are kind of vehicle that
they're riding around in and they feel like they're behind their,
their eyes in a way that they're not behind their knees.
You know,
their,
their needs are down there and,
and their,
their knees and the rest of their body or their kind of property in in a strange
way.
And
most people most of the time feel that they're in their heads and that they're,
they're a subject and they're a thinker of thoughts and that there's a thinker
in addition to the thoughts themselves.
They don't feel that there's thoughts arising and consciousness,
but most people feel that they are the thinker that is offering these thoughts.
And this actually goes right to the issue of free will as well because the
feeling of having free will is the feeling is there.
There's the other side of the coin of the feeling of being a self,
being a thinker,
being an author of actions and intentions.
And so I'm arguing that it's possible to cut through that illusion and that
there are good reasons to believe that it's an illusion based on just the
underlying neurology and,
and what we know about,
uh,
causality and what we know about the brain.
Um,
but uh,
you can actually penetrate this illusion subjectively and that the spirituality
is the act of cutting through it subjectively and no longer feeling that you're
an eco riding around inside of a bag of skin.
Uh,
and that that one's life gets,
uh,
improves in many obvious ways once one is able to cut through that,
that illusion.
And so that's so,
but it's,
it's kind of a sustained argument for a disciplined introspection in the form of
meditation and other techniques in the context of science and a discussion of
the brain and,
and why the concept,
the conventional notion of self doesn't make much sense given what we know about
the brand.
It's a very complex situation as well,
isn't it?
When you talk about the,
the,
the concept of self and that the person is a,
the consciousness is inside the body because it's also dependent upon how the
body feels like the body feels bad,
the consciousness is affected.
Either your thought process affected when you're sick,
your thought processes affected.
If you're at you,
you're stressed out.
If you're angry,
if you're,
if you're not getting exercise,
if you're not getting good nutrition,
if you're,
you know,
any,
any sense of non wellness in the body is reflected on the way that person
thinks.
It makes it more difficult to think with clarity.
So it's not as simple as like we're riding in this thing,
but this thing also affects the way you,
you know,
you,
when you think of you who you are.
I mean I'm vastly different pre and post workout.
I'm a different person.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean my thought if you presented me with the same situations,
the same dilemmas and problems pre and post workout,
I'd probably have a pretty different reaction to them.
Yeah.
And it's not even just all the variables aren't even within your own body,
your different in different relationships and different situations.
You walk into a restaurant and you're,
you're,
you're talking to the hostess and the,
and just the,
the frame around that interaction,
your expectation that you're in a restaurant talking to someone who wants to
seat you,
that changes your,
um,
just the way you approach human interaction.
And,
and if you had a different frame it would be a,
and,
and things will be different.
And it's,
it's almost true to say that different selves are called forth in those
different situations where you are,
you're just can't be the same self with certain people.
You just can't,
you can't even access it.
There are certain people who I am just effortlessly funny with because they are
such an easy laugh and I don't even know what it is.
It's just like there's something there.
There's,
they're so ready.
They're so poised to laugh and out for whatever reason.
Somehow the dynamics of our conversation are such that I am my funniest self
with that person without ever trying to be funny.
And I'm not,
I'm not aware of being on,
but I just keep falling into this thing and,
and,
and there are other people where,
you know,
I'm profoundly awkward with these people.
You know,
if you get put me in front of someone who is,
whose awkwardness is just tuned up a few notches beyond mine,
you know,
I become the aspergers guy,
with him.
And,
and it's,
it's,
um,
uh,
and,
and it's,
it's a,
it's odd,
but you're,
this is kind of a resonance that get set up and you,
it's,
it's based on,
you know,
conscious and unconscious mechanisms obviously,
that we have.
We have certain um,
uh,
you know,
variables that we,
we,
it's not to say you can't influence these things.
You can go into a situation with a conscious thought that you're going to
somehow transform it and that will have whatever effect it has.
But um,
and the mind is,
is complicated.
It's very complicated and it's,
a lot of that is dependent.
Our own consciousness is dependent on,
upon interacting with other consciousness,
which is one of the reasons why solitary confinement is such a horrible torture
to people.
Like when you separate a person's mind indefinitely from any other mind,
from any other interactions,
it freaks people out.
I was reading about this actually,
just,
just uh,
you're going to endanger forgetting this because it's interesting you raised the
point of solitary confinement because the experience that has got me to write
this book is very much like solitary confinement.
I went on meditation retreats in my,
mostly my twenties for weeks and months at a time.
And you really are just on many of these retreats just locked in a room,
meditating for 18 hours a day in silence.
You're not,
you're not making eye contact with anyone else.
You're not talking to anyone else.
And to some degrees,
it's not a,
it's obviously not like being in a prison,
but,
and you're,
you're there on your own,
on your own volition.
But this is many people's worst nightmare.
And it would have been at one point in my life.
It would have been my worst nightmare.
I went on a,
um,
it's actually where I start the book.
I went on a,
uh,
on outward bound when I was 16,
which has a wilderness program and in the mountains of Colorado.
And it was this 23 day course,
which culminated in,
in this ritual.
They called a solo where they put us,
they parked us all next,
uh,
on the,
on the outskirts of a mountain lake,
uh,
for three days and three nights.
And there was no food.
So we fasted and they were just told to just contemplate the universe.
And we were given no,
there were no books.
You know,
you,
all you can do is write in your journal.
And this was the first time in my life where I was actually in solitude.
I had,
this was the first time my life,
I had no one to talk to or nothing to read or nothing to distract myself with.
And I was in a tent.
I've got a tent and a sleeping bag and a blank journal and the most beautiful
landscape possible.
You know,
we're at almost 11,000 feet in the Sangre de Cristo Mountains,
Lillian.
So you just got,
you know,
the perfect stars every night.
And,
uh,
this,
this pristine mountain lake.
And I was as miserable as I've ever been in my life.
I'm a just crushed by,
by loneliness and boredom.
I mean,
just,
just that,
my mind was completely out of control and all I did,
my journal reads like they just,
the,
you know,
the Unabomber manifesto is a far more balanced,
expression of,
of,
of man subjectivity.
Then what I was up to at 16 on this,
uh,
solo and I was just making lists of the foods I wanted to eat when I,
you know,
it was just,
I was just craving every,
it doesn't make it list.
It just,
it was insanity.
And then when I came off of this after three days and learn that some of the
other people on,
on the course loved it and just felt completely transformed by having three days
of a,
with nothing to do,
I just,
I had no idea what to make of this.
I just like,
how could they have possibly,
how could that have not been anything but a torture for these people.
And so then I went from,
I was 16 there and it still took me a few more years to see a kind of path
forward and become interested in these things.
But I eventually went on to spend,
uh,
you know,
almost two years on silent retreats in my twenties,
in,
in circumstances of isolation and,
and sensory deprivation far worse than,
than that mean a mountain solo.
Uh,
cause I wasn't in an especially beautiful place.
And,
and,
um,
uh,
so it was a,
it really is,
it's your,
your life is such,
you're life is entirely dependent upon your mind.
Now,
it's not to say that external circumstances don't matter,
but the,
I mean,
there are people who can be genuinely happy and at peace in,
in terrible circumstances,
objectively terrible circumstances.
And there are people who have everything who are miserable.
And,
and so the fact that,
that,
that the,
the delta is that big and can be that uncoupled from external circumstances,
um,
shows you that it's really,
I mean,
you know,
you're,
you are almost entirely dependent on the character of your thoughts,
really.
I mean,
the,
the mechanism which I go into a,
at great length in the book is that the difference is really the difference
between being lost in thought and recognizing thoughts for what they are.
Most people are thinking every moment of their lives and aren't aware of it.
Are they in there?
They may have an abstract idea that they're thinking every moment of their
lives,
but they're not aware of the,
just the,
the automaticity and the relentlessness of this conversation.
Uh,
they're having with themselves and
to be identified with the next thought that arises in consciousness is,
is to be,
it's mirror prisoner.
I mean you are the,
you are then identical to whatever subjective,
state,
emotional state,
uh,
you know,
mood state.
It dictates.
So if it's,
if it's a self critical thought or a fearful thought or a hateful thought,
that's the,
that is the character of your consciousness in that moment.
And until you can break that spell until you can see thoughts as thoughts just
arising and passing away in consciousness,
you,
you see no alternative.
There's just no basis for an alternative.
And then you're as miserable as your thoughts.
Demand
was part of what was really fucking with you when you were 16 years old.
The fact that you were 16,
you know,
that's how old you were when you were up there on the mountain.
Yeah,
yeah.
Cause you have so few experiences to reference and the,
the time alone with your mind is more painful perhaps because you're developing
and you're not,
you're not quite a man yet.
You're not an adult.
You don't have personal sovereignty.
So you don't have like this,
I think like today if like you took me and said,
oh,
you have to spend a few days alone,
uh,
up in the mountain,
I'm so filled with things that I have to do on a regular basis.
I'm so filled with responsibilities with,
if I knew that I was going to do that,
I probably would find some pretty deep enjoyment in it because I have so many
life experiences to draw on.
So many thoughts in my mind.
That would probably be,
that would probably benefit from having that time to sit with nothing coming in,
but nature.
Yeah.
Well it's being 16 might've had a little to do with it because almost everyone
else on the course was maybe a decade older.
So they,
yeah,
and they had a better time.
But no,
I think it was,
I think there are 16 year olds who would've had a fine time and there are
definitely 20 year olds and 30 year olds and 40 year olds who would be miserable
in that circumstance.
Cause I see them on,
on meditation retreats and,
and uh,
on my own retreats I've experienced,
you know,
deep feelings of loneliness and sadness.
And because it's,
it's hard to leave everyone you love for three months.
You know,
it's like you go on what at whatever age,
you know,
25 is a,
I mean,
I guess I was 30 the last time I sat a exactly 30 last time I sat a three month
retreat.
Uh,
but he's just got you,
you're unplugging from your life.
You're saying goodbye to everyone,
you know,
if you,
for all,
you know,
someone's going to die while you're on retreat.
And so there's this real discontinuity with every project and every aspiration
and everything you have going on.
Um,
and,
and also most of the people in your life can't believe you're doing this.
It does not much support people.
Just,
it's just totally inscrutable.
Yeah.
That you would decide to do this and then you'll essentially lock yourself in a
closet.
I mean you like essentially you lock yourself in a room as big as you know,
these two tables and then you're just left with your thoughts.
And th the,
the problem is,
is that just thinking itself,
even thinking happy thoughts is stressful at when you,
when you actually,
when you really started paying attention to it,
that,
that just the sheer automaticity of it to just,
just to be,
just to not be able to stop the conversation and he just can't stop talking to
yourself for a second.
And that now you eventually you can eventually you become concentrated on,
in this case,
the practice I was doing as it was called Vipassana,
which is mindfulness meditation.
And the practice there is just to become very keenly aware of,
uh,
you start with the breath as an object of meditation,
but the,
but once you get a little concentration,
you opened it up to everything.
So sounds and sensations and even thoughts themselves become objects of
meditation where you're just noticing whatever arises in consciousness and,
but the difference between noticing the thought arise and pass away and being
lost in thought is,
is huge.
And this is the all important difference.
And it takes some real concentration to act,
to see a thought arise and pass away it because without the concentration,
all of a sudden the thoughts just you,
it just,
it just comes up from behind in a way and you are just,
you're just,
you feel identical in a strange way.
You feel identical to this sentence in your head.
You Do,
you feel there's a miss thoughts are just sentences and images.
And it's,
when you actually look at what a thought is,
it's,
it's very hard to see how you could,
how could ever define your subjectivity in the first place.
It's just like mere thoughts are no more substantial than the sound of my voice.
And you're just hearing the sound of my voice as a kind of appearance and
consciousness right now.
And it's not,
it's not defining you.
It's not,
you don't feel identical to it.
It doesn't have a real implication so much for how you feel.
Uh,
you're,
you're not,
uh,
it's just,
it's easy to see or to in this case here that it is a,
an just an appearance in consciousness.
It comes and it goes,
it starts and it stops and it's all sort of in plain view.
But with your own thoughts with the w w with your own voice,
it,
it sneaks up on you in a way that is,
and even to use the word you in this case is a little misleading because it,
but it,
it colors consciousness and trims it down in such a way that it just feels like
you.
It doesn't,
it doesn't feel it does it,
it's,
it's you,
you feel,
I mean the feeling of being a self,
the feeling that we call I,
the feeling of being an ego in the head is what it feels like to be thinking
without knowing that you're thinking.
It's the,
it's the feeling of this next thought.
Capturing consciousness.
So when you say that thoughts,
you are identical to thoughts.
So if you're thinking something really fucked up like a,
I'm fat,
I'm a loser,
I'm always going to be a loser.
Like that is identical to who you are because you are sort of framing yourself
in this thought that these thoughts that you're carrying around in your mind,
they are what's occupying your consciousness.
And that if those thoughts are in the forefront of your consciousness,
if they identify you,
you are,
that you are those thoughts and you are identical to that idea.
Yeah.
And their,
and their driving behavior and they're driving emotion and they're driving each
subsequent train of thought.
So it's,
it's,
it's determining the,
the,
the future expressions of your consciousness and your body as well.
So you're,
you're,
and again,
I'm not,
I'm not separating the mind from the body here.
I mean,
all of this is,
we could talk about this in terms of events in the brain as well,
but it's much easier to talk about it in terms of our first person experience
has thoughts and moods and emotions,
et cetera.
But,
um,
you know,
for the,
for the purpose of this argument,
you know,
there's no doubt that the brain is,
is doing this.
It's just,
we're not,
you know,
that side of the story that as much less to say about that side of the story at
the moment and it's not raining,
but you're,
you're whatever it is your personality,
your consciousness here at your center is sort of what
guides the brain one way or another.
Like it is possible to,
while in the middle of having these thoughts and say,
you know what,
I'm not going to entertain these anymore and I'm going to think about something
positive.
But it's very difficult.
Yeah.
Surprisingly difficult.
Even as someone like myself who spent a lot of times,
a lot of time meditating,
especially a lot of time in isolation tanks,
I,
it's still difficult every now and then if something's bothering you to just get
it out of your head.
Like,
especially for me.
Um,
one of my main issues is my work.
like,
uh,
like standup comedy for instance.
Like if I have a show and a I fuck a bit up,
if it goes wrong,
like if I have two shows in a night and I fuck a bit up on the first show,
I'm okay.
If I could redo it on the second show,
we're good.
But if I fuck it up on the second show,
God dammit.
Now I have to think about that thing all night and I'll try to let it go.
I'll try to get it out of my head.
But I rationalize it by saying the only reason why I've gotten so good is
because of this crazy obsession that I have with getting it correct.
And that when things go awry or when I go down a bad path,
it doesn't quite pan out.
And then I have to sort of restart the whole conversation on stage that that
uncomfortable moment.
And then the subsequent uncomfortable recollection of that moment is the very
motivation that's led me to be a good stand up in the first place.
So I kind of rationalize it,
but fuck man,
when I'm eating dinner after a show and I just flub one word that fucks up a
joke,
I'll be in the middle eating pancakes going,
shit,
I can't get it out of my head.
It doesn't matter if a wonderful wife and a beautiful family and great friends
and a fantastic job and a one to of just a fee,
a dream life.
It doesn't matter.
I flubbed the word you fucking idiot know like why I'm cutting
into my food.
Ah,
yeah.
Well that,
that's an interesting moment because,
um,
so there's a moment before the thought has arisen,
right,
where you have not yet remembered the flub lines.
So you're just cutting into your dinner and then it's an,
it's an image or part image,
part sentence,
something.
There's some expression of thought that arise in consciousness and you are,
you do not,
you do not witness it arise.
It's not like it's a difference between seeing it,
watching a movie and being totally lost in the movie.
Forgetting that you're sitting in a room with a bunch of other people looking at
light on a wall.
You're just,
you're totally captured by the movie.
It's difference between that and actually just seeing the screen,
the light on the wall,
hearing the sound of the projector,
seeing,
seeing the,
seeing the artifice and uh,
it's possible to see thoughts just as essentially like a play of light on the
wall.
He just use,
you see it before it captures you and the difference is total and it is kind of
like,
it's almost like playing a video game where you can now not get killed in the
same spot over and over again.
It's like,
it's like not losing in the same boss fight over and over again.
Yet we,
we lose in that same fight a thousand times a day.
But when you can actually see thoughts for what they are,
so the next time you flub a line and the next and the next time you recall it,
it's,
it's possible with,
and again,
it takes a certain degree of concentration to be able to do this,
but concentration becomes kind of a native capacity,
a certain point.
It's like Jujitsu or anything else.
I'm,
you have certain skills and you don't really lose them.
Um,
then you can just see it.
And it just comes and it goes and it doesn't have an end and it's going,
it's going.
It's really gone.
It's,
it's,
and it doesn't have the same emotional necessity.
It doesn't trigger the same mental state.
And now that's not to say that these negative mental states haven't had the,
the benefit that you ascribe to them.
So yeah,
it could be that you are as good as you are because you were motivated to not
embarrass yourself ever again because it felt so terrible.
Right?
So you hated this experience of flubbing align,
you hated the memory of,
of,
and,
and the reliving of it the next day.
You hated what it did to your,
your time with your family.
And so he thought,
the next tour,
I'm going to get this,
I'm going to,
I'm going to get up earlier.
I'm going to work harder,
et cetera.
So yeah,
that,
that's all part of the clockwork that's causing you to,
to hone your craft.
Um,
but I would argue that a little mental suffering those along way,
I think we know nine times out of 10 or 99 times out of a hundred,
we suffer unnecessarily and there's no good comes from it.
It's just,
it's,
it's not actually making us better people.
It's making us more neurotic.
People were more worried,
we're worse,
husband were worst.
And,
and it's time to,
to break that spell and [inaudible] and then you can,
you can selectively be as,
as uptight and neurotic as you want.
It can,
it gives you a kind of freedom to pick your,
your,
um,
your priorities in a way rather than be captured by just whatever the next
thought happens to be.
I've also found that for me personally,
the discipline and diligence are the,
uh,
the best mitigating factors for dealing with neurotic thoughts.
Like if I have an issue,
um,
one of the big issues,
if I've ever had anything go wrong was that I didn't work hard enough.
So if I know for a fact that I worked as hard as I could,
like back when I was competing,
that was a huge issue.
And it also,
uh,
mitigated nervousness.
Cause Look,
whenever you're involved in a competition as terrifying as a full contact
martial arts tournament where concussions are not just likely,
but it's someone in,
there's a hundred people fighting in this tournament,
someone's going to sleep,
something's going to get knocked out.
Is it going to be you?
And someone's going to get their nose broken,
someone's going to get hit.
A lot of people are probably,
if I,
if I trained really hard,
it's like I know I did everything that I could.
I ate right,
I slept right.
I put in all the practice,
I worked on all my weaknesses.
I,
you know,
I didn't neglect my strengths.
I was much less nervous,
much less nervous and much better at dealing with losses.
Whereas losses,
uh,
I think losses for martial artists can be insanely devastating.
Like I was listening to this interview with Travis Brown.
Do you know he has no UFC heavyweight?
One of the top,
top five guys in the world,
great fighter lost recently to Fabricio for doom in a title elimination fight.
So Fabrisio has gone on and he'll be fighting.
Cain Velasquez for the heavyweight title now in October in Mexico and a huge
October or November,
November,
believe it's November.
What are one of those?
Um,
he's fighting a Cain Velasquez for the title.
Huge fight.
It could have been Travis Browne,
Travis Browne lost the fight by decision and you know,
it was a,
it was,
he lost without a doubt.
But you know,
wasn't embarrassing.
It wasn't a,
he didn't get knocked out in the first round.
He didn't get submitted really quickly,
but he did lose the fight and it was apparently devastating to him.
I mean,
he's talked in great depth about lying in bed in the fetal position crying.
he's just fucking 250 pound gladiator and he's curled up in a fetal position
crying.
I mean,
the truth is I have to,
the ego is always curled up in the fetal position crying.
We all have that
a part of ourselves.
And it's,
um,
yeah,
I mean,
and that's what is so excruciating about the self and the self really is the
center of the center of our problem.
You know?
And when things are really going well,
we are consoled by how well they're going.
But we know it's,
it's vulnerable to change me.
You're only as good as your last appearance in some sense.
I mean,
I could do something incredibly embarrassing in the middle of this podcast and
that will be the thing I'm thinking about tonight.
And I'll be,
I'm thinking,
you know,
God,
I can't believe I fucked that up so bad and Joe's podcast.
Uh,
and that it's,
you're always vulnerable to that for the revenue for it,
as long as you are,
as long as you're in the center of this thing,
vulnerable to what other other people think about you and,
um,
a captive of your really crazy rehearsal of experience.
And when you,
when something like this happens to you,
just think of how many times you repeat it to yourself.
It's like you tell yourself the same story 15 times a minute for hours and it
doesn't strike you as insane,
but it actually is insane.
It's,
I,
if you're,
if you are thoughts,
could be broadcast on a monitor for other people to hear and they could hear you
repeat yourself over and over and over again.
It would seem starkly crazy.
It just,
it and yet it seems normal.
It's,
it's kind of like,
like the dream state where you go to sleep and you're in your bed and you,
you know,
you're,
everything's obeying the laws of physics.
And then in the next conscious moment you are,
you know,
at a party somewhere,
it's talking to someone who you know,
is dead and saying,
oh,
I can't believe you're,
you're alive now.
And,
and,
and then,
you know,
there's a gorilla in the room and,
and,
and none of this strikes you as crazy as,
I mean,
the,
what the craziest things about dreams is that the,
the mind seems to just accept them except these changes one after the other
without any sense.
That there should be continuity and this is due.
There's no question that this is due to the diminished activity of the frontal
lobes dirt during rem sleep.
And that we just,
our,
our truth or reality testing hardware has come largely offline during dreams.
But there's something analogous happening when we're just thinking in the waking
state,
because thoughts are,
thoughts don't make much sense because if the,
the repetition is,
we don't notice how crazy the repetition is.
And we would notice it if we were talking to each other.
If I was telling you the same thing 15 times in a row without a,
without honoring your expectation that I might move on to another topic,
you know,
you would,
you would notice and I would notice.
Right.
Um,
and,
uh,
yeah.
And,
and the other thing that's crazy about thoughts is that much of our thinking and
certainly our linguistic thoughts
or it's structured as though it were a conversation and we played both sides of
the conversation.
So I,
you know,
I'll,
I'll sit down here and,
um,
you know,
I said,
I came in,
I sat down and,
and uh,
I brought you a book and I wanted to sign the book.
And I see this pen over here and,
and I think,
oh good,
there's a pen over there right now.
I can see that there's a pen over there.
So who am I?
Why do I have to say there's a pen over there,
right?
Who am I telling?
Is there someone in me who can't see that there's a pen over there?
Right?
So there's a conversation that started like,
and I'm both sides of it.
That doesn't make any sense.
Right?
And yet we are,
our subjectivity is continually,
uh,
just,
it is,
it is discursive in that way and they're just voices talking to each other.
And there's not only,
not only are there not to have us in there,
there's not even one of us in there.
There's not,
the thinker isn't there.
But we seem to have two of them.
It's like we're constantly talking to mommy and Daddy.
Uh,
and we,
in fact,
I could be the way this conversation gets internalized,
cause you know,
I can see it in my kids now where they seem to all the Aleve.
Oh,
I'll listen to my daughter or playing by herself and she's talking to herself
out loud in the way that,
that,
you know,
you'd have to be sort of crazy to do as an adult.
But as a kid you're just,
you know,
you're just talking out loud.
Um,
and eventually we all learned to internalize that conversation.
But,
um,
and when you don't,
when people who can't internalize it will,
they're the crazy ones.
You know,
the,
the person who's walking down the street just saying,
oh good,
there's a pen over there and what w God,
we're,
we're late.
And,
uh,
God,
I know Joe Joe is gonna really be pissed.
Um,
I can't believe I sh I should have checked the traffic before I left.
So these are the kinds of thoughts I could think silently in,
in,
in the space of my mind.
But,
um,
and it wouldn't be starkly crazy,
but to verbalize them then you're a madman.
And that,
that difference between letting them out and just knowing to keep your mouth
shut is it captures a large part of the difference between being a proper
lunatic,
uh,
and in normal person.
But what I argue in this book is that it's a normal isn't good enough.
You know,
the normal,
the normal state of consciousness wherein you are just chased out of bed every
morning by your thoughts and you think,
think,
think every waking moment until you fall helplessly asleep at night.
Um,
that's not necessarily a happy place to be and it's not the only alternative.
And,
and so,
um,
and again,
and thought it's not that you're,
the goal is not to have a mind without thoughts,
but we need thoughts and,
and you can't,
you know,
everything we do as human beings for the most part,
d requires thought to get off the ground.
So our relationships are based on thoughts and our every public institution and
science.
But it's all,
it's this conversation we have with ourselves and with others is based on,
on language,
uh,
almost,
and uh,
and concepts that are mediated by language.
And,
uh,
so you need thought,
but the differences,
the difference is between thinking and knowing that you're thinking in really
knowing that you're thinking in the moment of thoughts arising or being lost in
thought.
And then when you're lost in thought,
it doesn't really matter.
The content is,
you're still confused about who and what you are.
I mean,
you gotta be thinking about the moment you can be thinking about the most
profound things in science or in,
in ethics or whatever it is.
But if you're just thinking without knowing that you're thinking there is a kind
of delusion there,
it is analogous to to the dream state in a way where you're just,
you're not,
it's not clear to you what's going on youth,
the youth,
you think you're the thinker of the thoughts.
You think you're offering your thoughts in a way that's you're,
you're not,
I mean,
cause thoughts just arise.
We don't,
we don't actually offer them.
Isn't it fascinating that even in higher education there's very little emphasis
whatsoever on controlling thoughts on,
on managing thoughts and managing your consciousness on figuring out how to best
analyze and a approach your own thinking process.
Because if you really think about it like what we were talking about earlier
about getting obsessed about something about something like getting into your
mind and and rolling over you like that kind of process and that kind of runaway
thought process can actually really negatively affect your life and it can start
a pattern that can create other events or,
or other sort of neurotic type thinking and that,
that that can affect your future.
And if you can manage that and sort of nip that in the bud,
like literally nip it in the bud,
like that could benefit your future,
that could benefit who you become,
how you evolve,
how you,
how you transform as a person,
a developing person.
And yet it's not really taught it is it because the people that are involved in
higher education aren't aware of it.
They don't know it.
It's not a common thinking process.
It's not a common thinking thought management process.
I mean,
what,
what is it that leads,
I mean,
someone like you who's had a higher education goes on,
writes a book like this,
then it becomes a part of whoever's reading it,
part of their mindset.
But if they don't have that,
if they don't have that book,
I mean,
they literally have to be introduced into someone outside of the realm of high
school,
College,
even masters,
Phd.
Very few people that go through that entire process are involved in a
comprehensive analysis of how to thank,
yeah,
well there's,
um,
mindfulness is actually in increasingly current now and it's,
it's a bit of a,
in some sense a fad,
but I think it's probably an enduring one because it's so useful.
Uh,
so mindfulness is now more and more being taught in schools.
And actually my wife has even taught it and it public school,
uh,
to kids as young as six.
So there's,
there's,
um,
really,
that's amazing.
Yeah,
it was amazing to see two,
you have this just picture,
a group of it was in a,
in a,
in a kind of lower economic,
uh,
public school and could probably 30 kids in the class and see picture 36 year
olds sitting in a circle.
And on the first day,
it's just that the chaos of 36 year olds.
And by the fourth week she was teaching one class a week.
They were sitting for 15 minutes in silence,
no screwing around.
They'll price unbelievable.
Yeah.
Just,
just,
and,
and they'll,
and that the stuff they were reporting back in terms of their experience was
amazing.
Uh,
but,
uh,
and the grip and the great thing about mindfulness is there's nothing spooky
about it.
You don't have to develop any kind of affection for Buddhism or beliefs in the
supernatural or a notion of Karma or mean nothing is all it is.
And there's nothing,
there's no thing that you're strategically adding to your experience by way of
meditating.
So you don't have a mantra and there's nothing,
there's nothing to explain.
All you have to do is pay
extremely close attention to whatever is arising of its own.
And you start with the breath because the breath is always there.
And it's just an easy thing to pay attention to,
but very quickly,
it's just,
it's,
it becomes,
you're just noticing sights and sounds and sensations and moods and thoughts.
And it makes perfect sense because if you want to know what it's like to be you,
if you want to have a very clear look at the nature of your own consciousness,
it just makes sense to pay attention.
And all you're doing is paying attention and there's no,
there's no conceptual overlay,
uh,
that you're,
you're applying that's monkeying with your experience to,
to try to change it.
So the goal in,
in that case isn't even,
you're not even trying to have a better experience,
although you can covertly hope to have a better experience and sort of corrupt
the process that way.
But you're really just trying to witness it.
Just the,
exactly what the character of your experience is in each moment.
So you're just noticing unpleasant experience without trying,
without pushing it away.
And noticing pleasant experience without trying to grab at it.
And it just so happens that once you develop that kind of dispassionate
attention to experience,
then certain very pleasant experiences start to come along because so much of
what's unpleasant about our,
our mind is our resistance to pain and are grasping at pleasure and our struggle
with experience.
So just paying attention really just,
just openly and without any agenda that for,
for the period of time you can do that,
you really have surrendered the struggle and that a tremendous relief just comes
with that process.
And so,
yeah,
so it's becoming something that they are teaching in schools,
uh,
at various ages and it's,
um,
I think the one downside to the way mindfulness is being marketed at this point
is that it's,
it's really being thought of as a,
almost a,
an esoteric version of an executive stress ball where you use it.
It's a,
it's a tool to optimize performance and it's,
it's a,
um,
you know,
it's the kind of thing that a CEO wants to have in his toolkit and,
and it's,
and all that's true.
It is,
it is a tool to optimize performance,
but it's much more a lie.
And it's traditionally intended to be much more like the large Hadron collider,
which is to say a real tool for discovering something fundamental in this case
about the nature of the mind.
And the purpose of,
of mindfulness is to discover that this self we think we have is an illusion.
And,
and,
and that the,
Eh,
so the real,
the real breakthrough is not just a little less stress or a little more
concentration or,
uh,
an ability to,
direct your mind,
uh,
where you want it to go.
So if you're,
you want to stay on a diet but you're tempted by the,
the chocolate chip cookie,
you can just get back on your diet without eating the cookie.
I mean,
that's one way in which you could use mindfulness,
but that's not really the center of the bull's eye center of the Bullseye is to
cut through this,
this illusion that we're all riding around in our heads as the,
you know,
as a ghost in the machine.
So we're not riding around in our heads.
No.
What are we doing?
Well,
there's just,
I mean there's [inaudible] you have a head,
but,
um,
the sense that there is a,
well,
interestingly you,
it's another way to talk about this.
I don't know if you've ever heard of this.
A writer Douglas Harden,
he was a,
um,
a British architect who wrote a book hold on having no head,
uh,
w which I'm so he's actually summarize the insight as a state of headlessness
and it actually does sort of capture the flavor of it in a way.
And he kept advocating that people just look for their heads.
So you're,
you're walking around and you,
you know,
you have a head,
but you actually don't see your head.
I mean,
you and I are talking now,
the only head UC is my head,
right eye.
So you see the world and my head is in the middle of it,
but you're hitting your head isn't showing up for you.
Right.
So you,
and you can,
you can notice that.
And if you look,
if you look for where I'm looking,
I mean,
you know,
I'm,
I'm looking at this thing that you think you have behind your eyes and if you
sort of incline your attention in that direction,
it's possible to have an experience where
that's,
that feeling drops away where you're just,
you actually no longer feel like you're behind your eyes looking across space at
me.
You just feel like there's just,
there's just this space in which my head is appearing and [inaudible] so it's
almost like you've been decapitated and it's like,
it's like a mad imagine being without a head,
you know?
Um,
and so anyway,
this is Douglas Hardin's metaphor for this,
this insight into selflessness,
but it does sort of capture the flavor of it.
It gets when it gets your attention moving in the right direction.
Because if you look for the center of experience that this and this feeling of
being a self behind the eyes is this feeling of,
of,
of there being a center to experience it.
So it's not just that,
it's not that we feel identical to experience.
We feel like we are having an experience.
We feel like we are a appropriating the experience and we're doing it from a
point behind our eyes.
We're doing it from this,
you know,
this sense of being a subject.
But if you look for the subject,
that sense of a center can drop out and then there's just experience.
Then there's a,
and,
and that's very much like the,
the kind of flow states or the or the,
the uh,
the unified kind of full immersion experiences that people have when you're
just,
when you're,
when you're paying attention to something so closely that you lose yourself in
it,
whether it's surfing or martial arts or sex or whatever it is,
you're just for the,
there can be these experiences where for a moment there is no distance between.
You're no longer looking over your own shoulder having the experience.
You're no longer trying to serve.
You're no longer thinking about how good the wave is or whether you're really on
it.
There's just a moment where there's just pure flow and you are just,
there's a unified field of experience and people get really addicted to those.
Those are,
those are,
those are peak experiences for people and they,
and then the rest,
why,
what person would serve for or do any thing else,
which is giving them access to this state of consciousness where they're just,
they're the self drops away and there's just experience.
But the thing is you can have that all,
you can have that in any moment.
You remember to look for it once you know how to meditate.
And that is just,
that is the nature of consciousness.
You don't have to be on a wave in a wetsuit.
You can just notice it,
you know,
uh,
just in,
in the middle of a conversation.
And that,
and that's,
that's a really the subject of this book
that flow states very different.
Um,
when you,
when you get great at something,
um,
whether it's martial arts or you feel it in stand up comedy as well,
it's a very similar state where I described it on stage as being a passenger.
You feel like you're a passenger on the ride?
Like I know the words are coming out of my mouth.
I know the timing.
I know,
but it's because I know the material so well and I'm so comfortable on stage and
I've put in so much time that I could reach that flow state.
And the same thing said,
uh,
can be said for Jujitsu or for kickboxing,
sparring or anything like that.
When you're,
when you're,
when you're locked in,
when you know you,
you,
you've done it so many times,
you're completely comfortable with the movements you a you under,
you've done all the training,
you put in all the work and the hours to get to that point.
It's not as simple as like you could be a white belt who meditates and reach a
flow state.
You can't,
oh yeah,
no,
it's not gonna this isn't gonna help you in Jujitsu.
I mean,
you're still going to be a white belt on the mat.
If you can drop your sense of self,
they'll,
there'll be no flow state.
You're going to get strangled.
There can be a flow state getting all getting strangled.
That's Masochism,
but you're still gonna not know what to do.
Oh,
well it can't be a flow state.
You'll be acting and reacting instead of just in the zone.
Well,
no,
you can be,
um,
no,
there's just the zone can be found anywhere.
It's just people
tend to only find it when there is this sort of mastery component.
And this,
the,
there's no,
there's no more error correction.
So,
so the problem that we all have when we're,
when we're tuning up a skill is that we're constantly making mistakes and
becoming incrementally more aware of the kinds of mistakes we're making and
correcting for them and getting better at correcting for them.
And there's all the self talk of,
of um,
you know,
what we should have done,
what we should do,
what we're hoping to do in the next moment.
Uh,
and flow states come when you get good enough for the most part.
So that all of that goes away.
So that like when you're playing golf,
you know,
there is no,
there are no more thoughts in your backswing.
You Take the club away and you're not thinking 15 different things.
As you know,
you're trying to hit the little white ball.
You're just,
you're just hitting a little white ball because you've just grooved your swing
so much that you just have no issue hitting the little white ball.
And so Jujitsu has its analogous component where you're not,
you're not still trying to remember what you should be doing when somebody is in
the middle of passenger guard away.
It's like you're just,
you're just part of the whole motion that is a,
you're not having to make these conscious calculations.
You're just moving.
And,
um,
so,
but you could,
you could be in,
you could be just as surrender to the present moment and free of self talk free
of neurotic expectations about what,
what's going to happen in the next instant or what she wished didn't happen a
moment ago.
Um,
and still be a total spazz on the mat.
I mean,
you could just,
this would just be,
it wouldn't help your Jujitsu.
It just would help your state of consciousness.
You know,
you can just drop your problem while realizing that you don't know what to do
when the guy's passenger guard.
Um,
but it's,
uh,
these,
um,
so the sip,
but people find these experiences really addictive and not addictive in a,
in a technical,
I'm not in a biological sense,
but they're just really captivating and they orient their lives around having
these experiences.
And the really dangerous thing is that people traditionally have found these
experiences in the context of religion and in the context of incredibly divisive
beliefs about paradise and,
and the unique validity of certain revelations.
And,
and so you have,
uh,
if people get tastes of,
of,
uh,
self transcendence in the context of really,
um,
uh,
frightening beliefs and then they become mildly attached to those beliefs
because those beliefs seem to,
they seem to be the only explanation for the,
the,
the meaning of these experiences.
So that's fast.
If you,
if you're a Christian and you feel,
you know,
absolute rapture and self transcendence while praying to Jesus,
well,
of course that's going to be a data point,
if not the only a data point in favor of the story,
that Jesus is the son of God and he's,
he's taking an interest in your soul.
And if you're a,
if you're a jihadist feeling that just,
Eh,
just as you get off the bus in Syria and you meet your recruiters at Isis,
that's going to,
it's going to prove to you that this is,
of course,
this is all laws will,
and this is,
you know,
you're fighting the one true,
cosmic battle against the evil infidels.
And you know that there's no question that these guys feel these very positive
states of mind.
Not,
they're not all running around depressed,
uh,
out there.
They're having peak experiences.
Uh,
and then there are people have peak experiences at burning man,
you know,
and have a totally different interpretation of their significance.
And what I'm arguing is that the only thing peak experiences prove is that if
they can't prove that all of these incompatible doctrines are true because they
can't all be true,
you know,
the jihadists and the d,
the fundamentalist Christian can't both be right.
And,
uh,
and not only are they not,
not the only people who have these experiences.
There are Hindus who have experiences that are,
that are,
that are identical but,
but,
uh,
are in the context of a totally different doctrine.
And atheists like myself have these experiences.
So it can,
these experiences can't prove that any of these doctrines,
these,
these provincial doctrines are,
are um,
true.
What they prove is that the human mind to susceptible to altered states of
consciousness and some of which are,
are really compelling and,
and worth having.
And yet we just have to understand them in a,
in a secular and,
and universal sense and a nonsectarian sense
is that what's going on?
When Pentecostal speak in tongues,
when they hit that,
what does that called Glossolalia when they start telling someone won a lot
[inaudible] like you reached this,
you know what I mean?
You use the state of mind where you're able to communicate this bizarre,
nonsensical language free of ridicule.
You're not worrying about how goofy you're sounding.
Well,
I think it's to some degree,
it is a kind of surrender of,
uh,
certainly one's dignity.
Uh,
um,
no,
I mean,
clearly it's got to feel pretty good.
And your surrender,
you're getting it.
You're getting rid of certain hangups.
It's like,
you know,
dancing wildly at a rave.
You know,
it's like if you're,
you're no longer uptight because you're real willing to ride around on the floor
with your aunts and uncles and you're on ecstasy.
All right.
No,
but in this case,
your head hostile.
Oh,
um,
uh,
yeah.
The state that you achieve that allows you to some la when you see those people
do that.
Like I just saw a guy do it in real life.
Uh,
yeah,
I've never seen it.
So I don't know what fear factor guy was.
Um,
he,
uh,
he actually won the,
event,
but it's so hilarious.
Like the event was so ridiculous.
Like some of the fear factor events were completely ridiculous.
And this one particular event was uniquely ridiculous because it had absolutely
nothing to do with your ability to overcome something or your ability to,
uh,
to even figure your way out through something.
You had like a fort,
you were attached to a harness and the harness was attached to a cable that
attached to,
to,
uh,
like,
a wire so that you,
you actually didn't fall off this cliff,
but you were on a four by four and you drove the four by four off the cliff.
So you just drove,
he hit the gas and you,
you were yanked up and the four by four fell and whoever's four by four went the
furthest commitment.
Yeah,
yeah,
let's full commitment.
But there's no skill involved.
You're just hitting the gas and going off a cliff at the same point on the cliff
as everyone else.
And this one guy,
one,
and he was convinced that this was the will of God and he was [inaudible].
He started doing this thing and I was like standing next to him watching this.
I was like,
this is so strange.
You know,
it was a,
it was weird to watch someone,
first of all,
if you are speaking in tongues,
what a shitty language it is.
Cause you keep repeating the same noise over and over again.
It has none of the structure of a language where people have analyzed it and
it's clearly bullshit.
Yeah.
It sounds like bullshit.
It would be interested,
but it,
it,
it would be interesting if it weren't,
you know,
it,
it's possible that somebody could produce a performance like this where it
would,
it would have linguistic structure and then people would just be spinning out
trying to figure out how this is,
you know,
how it is possible.
But no,
it's just,
it's just gibberish.
But it's a similar jibberish that's what made me wonder like how weird this is
a,
because this,
this jibberish and I,
I,
maybe it's repeating because he's pentacostals hanging out with each other and
maybe it's like an accent sort of a thing.
Like one person develops a Boston accent,
although people around them have that Boston accent.
But,
um,
when I watched this guy and then I watched,
Robert Tilden,
he was one of my favorite bullshit artists that's on a late night,
religious television.
He's one of those guys that Jesus wants you to.
He actually said this one time,
he goes,
every time you write a check to me,
Satan gets a black eye.
I fucking love that quote.
Yeah.
But he does the same thing.
He goes,
some of them it's the same summer law.
My law like that kind of what they're teaching it to each other.
It's a kind of performance and they have,
they've all gone to school on each others performances,
but I'm not,
I'm not insinuating in any way that's actually divined but I,
um,
I was just weirded out by the similarities and their bullshit language and his
bullshit language.
Like,
I dunno if this guy's a Robert Tilden fan,
but he was doing that same summer,
like the,
it's a,
it's weird,
the Jibberish is similar.
Is it like,
just they're not that creative.
Like,
you know,
like,
there's not that many ways to make nonsense sounds quickly.
And so the,
I mean there's probably,
there's probably some constraints and it would be interesting to see
if,
if you're native Chinese speakers would,
would produce the same names.
They might,
they might have different,
I would have expected what it would be different.
That would be interesting like to teach because Christianity has um,
spread to a lot of other countries,
Asian countries.
If he could get Pentecostals and Korea.
Yeah.
And see if they,
you know,
if they have some sort of a or functions to fund that study.
Yeah,
let's write a check to do it is to,
you know,
it would be so unethical because you get these poor people believing that
they're really talking in tongues and just so you can listen to their,
their lingo.
Yeah.
Well it's interesting to know where the line between self deception and
conscious fraud is placed and I guess it's like the,
those fake martial arts videos we watched last time I was here.
You know,
the guys who are taking those dives would there kito master.
It's just hard to see.
It's hard to see that it's,
I conscious fraud entirely.
It cause people have too much time invested and obviously the guy who invites
someone from another school to come punch him in the face.
That guy w w w was believing his own bullshit.
I mean he thought his,
at a certain point he must have been convinced that he had this power because
his,
he,
you know,
for a decade or more he sees people flop around at the mirror,
the hint of a,
of a touch.
Oh kind of brings us back to what we were talking about earlier in that when
you're around certain people,
you're a different person in that when these guys are around,
all these people that really believe that they have some divine ability to
control that people's bodies with air.
Just like there's something about doing that over and over again and reinforcing
that belief that it seems to be like they are a master when they're around those
people.
But then when you put them around someone who knows nothing about them and treat
them just as a,
an opponent in the martial arts contest and head kicks them,
like all of a sudden it's gone.
Like,
where's my power?
Who am I?
I'm not,
I'm not a magician.
I'm not a wizard anymore.
Now I'm just a guy getting the fuck beat out of me by some other martial
artists.
And this is a terrible,
terrible scenario.
I've found myself in
so great about real martial arts.
It is,
it's like science in that you're running an experiment that is as close to a,
a real experiment as you can run without anyone getting killed and you're seeing
what works.
And that's what the UFC was in the beginning.
The UFC was just this absolutely enthralling science experiment because no one
knew what was gonna happen.
You throw you a,
what's going to happen when you throw a boxer in with,
uh,
with,
karate legend with a sumo wrestler with it and,
and just know rounds and just,
just let it,
let the clock run and see what it is.
Just so now,
obviously now I'm now I'm telling you a your own business,
but I'm at now,
everyone has gone to school on everyone else's style and everyone knows enough
Jujitsu on the ground to be able to nullify the advantage of Jujitsu.
And so now everyone has kind of converged on the,
the common universal toolkit combatively that you want.
Um,
and so you're not getting these v the experiment isn't,
it has basically played out.
Now everyone's going in with the same expectation that when you're standing up,
you want to be able to kick and punch like a kickboxer or like a Muay Thai
fighter,
somebody who really knows how to kick and punch.
And when you're vertically grappling and you really do want to be,
uh,
like Randy couture or somebody who's got,
you know,
real,
uh,
clinch and pummeling skills and Greco skills.
And then when you go to the ground,
you want Bjj or Samba or something that gives you those skills on the ground.
And,
uh,
so there's not that many surprises left in store.
But,
um,
I mean maybe,
maybe the
wrong,
maybe there's some totals,
which is interesting because martial arts in in many ways really is a scientific
endeavor that because
so much of it,
it involves leverage and force and physics,
but also the introduction of new variables that haven't been,
they haven't been practiced.
And when you introduce new variables like Noo,
noo kicking techniques,
especially like when Andrew's character,
something that annoys you or even traditional kicking techniques that had been
discarded.
Like when Anderson Silva Front kick Vito Belfort and the face and knocked them
out,
everybody was like,
Holy Shit.
Like who the fuck said that coming to have the highest level guys ever,
you know.
And he introduces the original technique.
That is the number one technique you teach.
When I used to teach white belts,
the first kick,
I would teach them as a front kick because it's easy to learn.
You pick your knee up,
extend your foot forward.
And I would teach them to do it at knee level and then,
you know,
eventually you go to chest level.
Then you know,
the rare front kick to the face.
But nobody ever used it in a UFC belt.
But now it's incredibly common.
It's like one of the main,
you know,
a Travis Brown,
the guy we were talking about early knocked out Alistair Overeem,
front kick to the face and for years we had none.
Um,
Terry Adam when he first knocked out or Edson Barboza when he first knocked out
Terry Adam with a wheel kick to the head.
That was in 2000,
I want to say 12 or 13.
So there had been no wheel kick knockouts for the decade plus of the UFC.
I mean it was.
Now do you think that two decades,
in fact,
do you think that's somewhat an artifact of
everyone's expectations being so trained now that you got me given all of the
fights that have happened and,
and,
and how all these traditional techniques have been discarded that now no one is
expecting anything like a traditional kick.
So that it's almost like you threw a wheel kick in a boxing match where you've
got two boxers and,
and you know,
w one has absolutely no expectation that kicks or even going to be involved.
And all of a sudden you will kick him.
Right.
Um,
is it,
is it just the sheer novelty?
Is there
something else going on that is just that it's you,
that,
that once you have all of the other skills that are the real foundation for
being a good MMA fighter,
then you can experiment with Goofy,
traditional moves that wouldn't have worked if you were a pure traditional
martial artists.
Mary,
do you think if you brought in just a pure traditionalist who was like one of
the guys who showed up at UFC one now who really could only do things like wheel
kicks and you know,
he just basically,
he was just a straight up,
uh,
I dunno.
Tank pseudo guy,
right?
You bring him into the UFC.
Is he gonna get off of Lucky?
We'll kick and he exactly that circumstance or,
or as he would have to have all the other techniques as well.
But um,
I think it's,
it's pattern recognition and a,
not very many people who are martial artists in the sense of mixed martial
artists,
uh,
fighting in the UFC can actually do those techniques.
I've worked out with high level guys like guys who are fighting for titles,
guys who are,
you know,
top 10 ranked.
And I've worked out with them showing them martial arts techniques like
taekwondo techniques and they don't know how to do them.
And it's amazing.
You see,
you're talking about high level MMA guys who don't have a background,
a kicking background,
don't have a taekwondo based background,
right?
Or showed AECON.
There's a few uh,
kicking,
uh,
disciplines that incorporate wheel kicks and a lot of high kicks like acts,
kicks and things along those lines.
And they literally don't know the effectiveness of these techniques because they
don't,
they don't do them.
So they,
they,
what they do is a lot of Moitai leg kicks and knees,
the body,
elbows in close get the take down ground and pounds,
submissions,
things that you see much more common.
And when I've tried to teach them these specific techniques,
it's amazing how incompetent they are at them.
They haven't even tried to learn,
we'll kicks,
right?
So what I'm teaching them wheel kicks,
you know,
they're like their bodies all awkward and thrown it where they don't have like a
fluidity that you need.
Like an Edson Barboza has where he,
you know,
he's standing there and then boom and he throws it.
So if you're not used to sparring with a guy like that,
you don't know that that can come at you like that.
You're used to a certain distance as well.
The distance between,
uh,
where a person could land a leg kick and a person could land a wheel kick is a
little bit different.
And if you don't know you're in range.
Yeah.
There's also,
um,
some kicks like spinning backaches or a little bit easier than a wheel kick.
The wheel kick requires a lot of flexibility.
So you might anticipate a spinning back kick and then the kid comes up high and
you only have a millisecond.
You have the reaction time and action time are two very different things.
That's why sucker punches work.
The reason why I sucker punched works is a punch.
The action time is like a hundredth of a second,
but reaction time,
it's like a 10th of a second.
That's a big gap.
So the amount of time that it takes for someone to punch you in the face and the
amount of time it takes,
you go,
oh,
this fucking guy's going to punch me in the face.
Oh Shit,
I've got to duck.
You don't have time crack.
You get hit.
And that's why soccer punches work.
And that's why actually this opens a up to,
I don't know if we want to go
recklessly in this direction,
but this,
this opens up into the ethics of uses of violence and use it.
You just kind of use of force philosophy and you have something like,
you know,
what's been going on in Ferguson,
that were around this shooting.
Um,
people have erroneous assumptions about how violence unfolds.
And as you're saying,
like if you're,
if you're deciding to block or to defend yourself in the mirror,
once a guy has thrown his sucker punch,
you are nine times out of 10 too late.
I mean you're just,
you,
you need a distance.
Was WWE at that moment.
Yeah.
You didn't need awareness and awareness of possibility and if,
but if,
you know,
if,
uh,
and I'm,
I'm not making any claims about knowing what happened in Ferguson with the
shooting.
I mean he could be,
um,
every inch of the homicide that many people seem to think it was.
But,
um,
the reality is that cops are walk having to work in a universe where,
you know,
they do a traffic stop and someone pulls out a gun and shoots him in the face.
Right?
And so,
so they have to assume,
uh,
that that is a possibility no matter what you look like,
no matter what kind of car you're driving.
And so you see the cops are incredibly on edge and you see them,
you know,
unbuckling their,
the strap on their holster as they just walk up to give you a ticket.
Um,
but it's because they don't have,
they don't have the luxury of time.
They can't wait to see you produce a gun.
And then they say,
okay,
now my lethal force option is,
is,
is beyond reproach.
And so,
uh,
I mean the only mode to be in with a cop,
no matter how much of an asshole he might be is,
is to be compliant.
And then you,
you,
me sue him later in the,
in the middle of negotiating a with a cop.
You the,
no matter how,
um,
unjustified the arrest may seem or that's not the time to be telling him he's an
asshole or,
or talking about how you are such a good guy and,
and this is a violation of your civil rights.
You just,
you do what he says and then you know,
sue the cops later.
But it's just,
yeah,
cause cause well the filter he is,
is seeing everything through is,
is this cause it was what the,
the sheer fact that a cop has a gun on his belt makes any contact,
a potential lethal encounter for him.
Let me say you just,
you just go hands on a cop.
You know,
you push a cop,
he doesn't know that you're not going for the gun on his belt.
He doesn't know that you're going to not push him into,
into a car and he'll be knocked out and then then you're going to get his gun.
And He,
so it's just,
it's all deadly for a,
from a cop's point of view.
And so you very few people understand that if I had a friend who was,
who was stopped by a cop,
um,
and this is,
you know,
this is a middle aged Jewish guy who's like,
in his mind the least dangerous person on earth and why on earth is a cop
stopping him.
And,
and uh,
my friend said something to the cop and the cop on a latched as,
you know,
the,
the top restrain on his,
on his gun.
And my friend said,
what,
you're going to pull out your gun on me with the,
and,
and the cops that,
what does a bad guy look
and that and that just sort of cut through it for my friend and my friend.
Just,
you know,
my friend,
my friend knew he was not a bad guy,
but there's no way for the cop to know he's not a bad guy.
Um,
and people just don't,
people are just not aware of that and they're interacting with cops and it's,
it's a,
it's dangerous for everybody.
Yeah.
The naivete of someone who is a good guy,
who doesn't know bad people and doesn't know what people mean.
You just go on Youtube and watch,
um,
assault on police officer,
just youtube assault on police officer.
There's a a hundred videos that you can watch where people sucker punch cops.
There's this horrific video of this guy getting pulled over and uh,
he's with his son and a,
it's on a dash cam of the police car there.
The lady pulls him over and uh,
she asks him for his license and registration.
The guy gets out of the car,
he's given her a stuff and he says,
well,
and she's like,
sir,
I need you to turn,
turn around and put your,
uh,
you know,
lean your body up against some of the,
I'm going to handcuff you.
And he's like,
why are you going to do that?
Bang.
He punches her in the face and before you know what?
She's unconscious on the ground.
He's beating on her,
his,
his son is screaming for him to stop.
Or his daughter was screaming at him.
I forget which one it was for him to stop beating this cop up.
But he's beating the fuck out of her and she's unconscious and he takes her
gone.
And you know,
I don't know how it ended.
I shut it off.
But there's a lot of those.
You can't assume that someone's a good person.
You don't know who they are,
you don't know anything about them.
And also the psychology of being a police officer.
The,
the PTSD involved in day to day interaction with criminals,
day to day,
interaction with people lying to you day to day,
interaction with danger,
violence,
car accidents,
death over and over and over and over again.
You've gotta be on edge all the time.
And then thinking,
is this the day where they get me?
Is this the day?
Am I going to be the guy who gets his gun taken away?
Am I going to be the guy who gets shot?
Like this guy I saw on a video or you know,
it's,
there's,
there's so many instances that a cop has to think about when you have that job.
I started argued,
someone made this really irresponsible,
irresponsible,
ignorant,
um,
Twitter posts about how being a cop isn't dangerous because look how many cops
die as opposed to look how many,
um,
you know,
x amount of a fireman or whatever,
whatever job it was die that cops actually are less likely to die than many
industrial workers.
But that's because they have protocol.
That's because they think they think ahead.
That's because they have so many cops have been killed,
that they have all these standards of practices in place to make sure that it
doesn't happen.
That's why I'm going to cop approaches a car.
He does have his hand on his gun.
That's why he does say keep your hand on the wheel.
That's why he does say licenser edge place.
You keep your hands where I could see them license and registration please.
Like they have to be aware because if cops just treated it like,
hey,
cops never die.
Like I saw this Twitter post,
it says like one 10th of 1% of cops die.
Like I don't have to worry about that shit.
Hey man,
where are you going?
Boom,
you're shot in the face.
You know that the,
the statistics are often inaccurate when it comes to dealing with something
where someone is,
uh,
there's many practices that are in place to protect someone from inevitable in
variables are an inevitable variables that a cop is going to face.
Yeah.
They also have much less training than you would expect,
especially with like hand to hand skills.
I mean you have so much more training than even,
you know,
elite swat operators in terms of your hand to hand skills so big.
And so it's um,
it's the public has an expectation that the only justification for producing a
gun if you're a cop or if you're anyone is if the other person has a gun or some
similarly lethal weapon.
I even,
I think so some people think that,
you know,
a knife isn't lethal enough to justify the use of a gun.
Right.
Uh,
but the truth,
but the fact is cops are not superheroes and they can't handle a,
uh,
a person who is bigger than them,
stronger than them,
younger,
younger than them,
and more aggressive than them.
Who gets the jump on them.
I mean,
it's just,
you know,
that,
that's,
that's a tall order even for a black belt in Jujitsu,
you know,
it's,
it's not,
um,
and so their,
their,
their tool belt is,
is there for a reason and say they need to,
they need tasers and they need guns and they need,
they need force of numbers in order to even do the job against somebody who
doesn't have a gun themselves.
And,
and so it's,
um,
it's a very,
it's a,
it's a hard job.
And I've got a huge respect for a cops all the while knowing that there are
undoubtedly some bad cops who were just psychopaths and status and shouldn't be
in the job.
And there are a lot of cops who are,
who are frankly not as trained as they should be in any him,
even with guns.
And they're not as stressed of them.
Yeah.
They're not as trained with guns as they should be in there,
not as trained hand to hand as they should be.
Um,
and that's,
um,
you know,
that's just,
it's,
it's doing them a disservice and it's doing,
doing the public a disservice.
But,
um,
still even if you're well trained,
uh,
you as a cop,
you were moving into situations which it's just untenable to give this stranger
the benefit of the doubt.
You know,
you just see,
so you,
you,
you have to,
you look like a,
uh,
someone who's escalating force too early.
If you're a,
if you're a cop who's just taking,
um,
totally rational steps to stay safe in a situation where,
where there's just basic uncertainty as to what you're dealing with.
I think we're requiring so much of someone who becomes a police officer that
it's almost a job that no one can be qualified to do me.
Or you're acquiring psychology or acquiring the physical ability to defend
themselves against a,
a wide variety of people where you have zero idea of what their background is.
You know,
you see some young guy and he looks reasonably athletic,
have no idea what he can do to you.
Yeah.
He might be a cigarette smoker with no martial arts experience whatsoever,
or he might be a Moitai champion.
And if we're with,
you're within range of him,
all of a sudden,
boom,
you're unconscious.
You have no idea what happened.
He punched you in the face so fast.
You have no idea.
And the,
the,
the other thing about when people start talking about cops and,
and violence and danger,
most people have never been involved in a physical altercation with a trained
martial artists.
They have no idea how vulnerable they really are.
They're walking around.
I've seen people get in arguments before and get crazy with people and start
fights and then watched a fight take place.
And I,
and I,
it boggles my mind,
I'm like,
why was this guy so confident to get into a physical altercation?
But he's got no idea what you do with a guy with cauliflower ear.
That's usually a typical for you guys.
You know,
guys got tats like you and he's got cauliflower ear and you still got somebody
mouthing off to him.
If it happens.
It happens all the time.
And I think some people think they're going to bluff their way out of it.
Or I think there's so much ignorance and ego involved in the average person when
it comes to physical altercations.
I think it would do a lot of people good just to realize how vulnerable they
are.
And when I was a black belt in taekwondo,
when I had national,
uh,
level comp competitor,
I'd won multiple tournaments.
And then I started doing Jujitsu.
I got mall,
I mean mauled,
not mall,
like,
um,
well,
you know,
I kind of held them off for a little while but eventually got me,
no,
like,
like instantaneously destroyed
saline with a five year old,
you know,
it's like the five year from the five year old's point of view.
There just,
there is absolutely nothing to do.
It's just,
you know,
and,
and that's,
that's what I felt like the first time I got on the mat with a,
with a Jujitsu black belt.
I thought,
I,
I thought I would have some sense of just how to stop the problem from now,
from a golfing me.
And it was just,
it was,
it's totally hopeless and it's hopeless in a way that,
and that's why I wrote that blog post originally.
The pleasures of drowning,
it's like drowning because when you're
drowning doesn't make much sense.
It's,
it's hard.
Like you're,
you're moving,
you know,
you get in the water and you're moving your arms and legs,
like you've seen people swim,
you know,
it's like,
Whoa,
how could there be that much to it?
And in fact,
once you know how to tread water,
there isn't much to stay in a afloat.
But if you don't know how to tread water,
you don't know how to swim.
All that moving of are your arms and legs is just,
it's completely ineffectual.
And you could be making 100% effort and you're still going straight to the
bottom.
And it's,
um,
and with Jujitsu it was,
it's just so,
uh,
it's so surprising to him to feel like you have some skills cause you've done,
if you've trained for years and some standup art and you did a little,
you know,
he took some Krav Maga classes and you did some stuff on the ground and you,
you have a basic feeling that,
you know,
hey,
I would poke him in the eyes if it really got bad on the ground.
Um,
and then you get on the mat with somebody who really has
a deep Jujitsu game and it's just,
it's like wrestling a Martian.
Well,
there's also levels.
Like,
you know,
I'm a black belt,
but I,
there's guys who I roll with.
It could treat me like I'm a blue belt.
That's the reality of the situation.
If I'm,
if I'm rolling with like Jock,
Hurray,
I'm going to get strangled and I'm,
I've been doing it for 20 years and it doesn't matter.
So how,
so how long do you think you could hold off?
Uh,
the tap with the best person?
If,
if you're down with Marcella Garcia or somebody who a couple minutes at the
most,
and that's all I have to be on full defense.
That's,
that's the difference.
Like if I'm rolling with a guy who was a purple belt,
I go on offense.
Like if I'm rolling with someone who is below me or my level,
I'm going,
I'm always defensively aware but I'm going full offense.
But if I'm rolling with a guy like a Marcella Garcia is all defense.
Yeah.
It's all like just,
it's all like trying to hold someone off and work.
Like if you knew that you were going to be a working against a guy like Marcella
Garcia and you had like months to prepare,
I would just bench press and do everything about pushing away.
Everything is pushing away reps and pushing away,
but eventually you're gonna fuck up.
You know,
there's,
it's like the good analogy also is debating because if you debate the average
person who has a neurological standpoint on something,
like I've watched you debate many people,
uh,
when it comes to religion and things along those lines.
And when you have the tools in place,
those tools being logic,
reason and defined arguments about different variables.
And then the other person doesn't and they have emotions and a religious
ideology on their side.
And it just,
uh,
overconfidence,
just,
it's just having this a ridiculous idea that they're right and they're,
they're gonna win and they go in there and they just get tied up like so quickly
are arguments get destroyed and they,
they,
you see them get flustered and you see their words come out,
I'll conky and they get their heartbeat raises.
And I love of what,
there's one a debate that you did with,
uh,
I don't remember the gentleman's name,
but he was a rabbi and a,
you were like David Wolpe.
Yes.
And he got so dramatic and the way he was talking,
which made it more ridiculous because you have this very calm,
very flat way of expressing yourself,
which makes anyone who's super emotional and super like dramatic,
seem preposterous.
It seems you seem more ridiculous cause you're all,
and what God has said to us and the word of God and all this like,
and then you know,
you're like,
well that's not exactly the fact that,
what the reality is this and this and that.
And this is what we know about neuroscience.
This we know about life and this is it.
Just because of that doesn't mean this.
And you see the,
uh,
they're drowning,
drowning,
except they don't necessarily know they're drowning.
And the crucial difference.
And the one reason why Jujitsu is so satisfying is that there's no,
there's no tap out in a debate.
I mean,
say that you're never,
they're never forced to acknowledge,
right.
They lost the point.
That's so true.
No matter how obvious it becomes to the audience or do you,
and,
and um,
it actually,
there's one thing that's kind of insidious about debates,
which I'm sorry,
actually terrible in politics.
I hate it when I see this and political debates where laughter is a surrogate
for tap out.
And so that if you can get a big laugh in a debate,
no matter how terrible your platform is as a politician,
no matter how wrong you are on the,
on the facts,
if you,
if you can get a big laugh line,
you know,
you,
you know you or know Jack Kennedy,
right,
right.
That is,
that's all that anyone cares about at the end.
And it's like the standup standup comic wins the debate.
Um,
certainly politically and it's even,
it's even true in,
in,
um,
in other contexts.
So it's a politically,
it's everything.
It's everything.
Jack Kennedy line was,
what was that 88 or something like that?
When was that?
What year was that?
That's Dan Quayle,
right.
Dan Quayle.
And for these,
these questions,
who is the senator?
Who's debating?
Lloyd Benson?
Yes.
Yeah.
I knew Jack and he set them up,
man.
It was like Jab,
Jab,
overhand.
Right?
I knew Jackie Kennedy and Jack Kennedy was a friend.
You are no check Canada.
And the whole lot is like,
oh shit.
You compared yourself to a dead guy who was like the greatest president ever who
was shot in this national scandal and the,
I mean,
the whole,
all the buildup to it.
I mean,
it wasn't even like he was comparing himself to Theodore Roosevelt or someone
else who was dead,
you know,
Jack Kennedy a fuck man.
It was just checkmate.
Like he could never have come back from that.
But it's true.
I mean,
in that gate is right here.
In that case,
we were,
you know,
I was certainly on the side of,
uh,
you know,
certainly against coil there.
But,
um,
you see it happen in,
in cases where it's,
you know,
the,
the losing party,
the party who is on the,
on the wrong end at the laugh is really the one who was making the most sense in
the debate.
They just,
you know,
you,
you just know that that debate was a disaster for the specialty.
If the audience is stacked and you've got a bunch of religious people in the
audience say,
yeah,
why don't you just tell,
tell that to God when you see him at the Purlin.
Yeah,
I think that that can definitely,
well it's also people are looking,
they're looking for a result and they can decide that that result is correct.
You know,
he could through sheer force of will and through cognitive dissonance,
the all the people in the audience refusing to recognize the actual thing that's
being debated but rather not a point that they get to express themselves.
Well,
this is,
I agree with him.
Jesus doesn't want us Molech queers marry each other,
you know,
and they just hoot and Holler and all that loud noise in that one room.
Well that's what's crucial about laughter.
Um,
it's a really only laughter and applause are the only moments where,
you know,
as a member of the audience that everyone's the same page because that's the
moment of when everyone helplessly breaks into a laugh.
I mean,
this is you as a comic.
This is,
this is the,
this is your career,
you know,
provoking these moments.
But that as it like as a public speaker.
I,
it's interesting,
you know,
I don't,
put a lot of laugh lines in my lectures,
but what I recognize that if you go long enough without having a laugh line in a
lecture,
you sort of lose the sense of that everyone is with you.
Cause it's just silence.
Right.
So I'm talking for 20 minutes and I'm hoping people are with it.
I hope,
I'm hoping they're finding this interesting.
I'm hoping there's,
I'm making sense,
but it's only the next time they laugh that truly reassures me that for that
moment I have the entire room and that's,
and that's so it's,
it's a,
um,
it's interesting.
Yeah.
Public speaking is a very unique art form.
Uh,
public speaking in terms of like lectures,
when you see people give public talks about a book that they have,
like the,
the,
the ability to hold people's attention.
It's like there has to be something that you're doing some dramatic moment.
Either you have to have a certain amount of charisma or you have to have a
certain sense of humor.
You have to have something to be able to sort of glue the whole thing together.
You know,
it's hard to listen to someone like lectures that like boring professors give.
I remember like being in class,
listening to some of those lectures and 10,
15 minutes in I'm checked out.
I mean I'm fucking thinking about my laundry.
I got to do and I'm sort of paying attention cause I have to,
but I'm bored as fuck.
But if the guy was humorous,
like I remember I saw a debate once between,
uh,
a member of the moral majority.
Do you remember the moral majority and Barney frank,
who was an openly gay back then,
this was when I was in high school and a Barney frank was a humorous and uh,
he was,
he was so good at,
he knew how to publicly speak and uh,
it was in a small auditorium and Newton south high school in like 1984 or
something like that.
And Barney fry,
he was mocking this guy with an American flag on his lapel and what he was
trying to,
he was essentially setting up with this guy was trying to project to you like,
this is who he really is.
This is what he's trying to protect.
Like he's like,
it's wearing a superhero outfit.
Like,
oh,
he's so concerned about the morality of America,
but what he,
what he doesn't understand is this.
And I think that you,
people are smart enough to realize that.
And he was funny and I remember like listening to one guy talk and it was like
sanctimonious and fucking boring.
And it's just,
it's just,
it didn't know how to talk very well.
And the other guy,
even though it was just two people's opinions,
it was more pleasant to listen to.
It was more entertaining.
So he was better at it
because of that.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah,
the days of,
um,
being able to get far without being able to speak well in public or are behind
us.
I think,
and it's,
it's interesting to,
this is something that I discovered a few years ago,
I actually blogged about this.
Um,
uh,
Jefferson had a morbid fear of public speaking and gave exactly two speeches,
two state of the unions in his two terms as president and just read them in a,
in a kind of crushed monotone cause he was so terrified.
Uh,
and that was,
that was it.
We could have heard those.
Yeah.
I'm going to put,
I'm sure they were terrible.
They get,
they were barely a bit that for people at the time,
uh,
reported that you could barely hear what he was saying and he's just hoarders of
his.
Yeah.
And they,
and he just,
he just,
he was,
and he would just walk like a condemned man to the scaffold,
you know,
when he had to give these speeches and he avoided it because he,
he was so uncomfortable doing it,
but he could avoid it.
Can you imagine being the president United States now and not feeling
comfortable getting Haskell?
It's impossible.
Well,
fully on the force of his writing,
he had the influence he had.
Isn't it fascinating too that you need not just to be able to speak well
publicly,
but you need to have a certain style of communication that where you address
large numbers of people.
It's completely unnatural.
Like Obama has the long pauses in this very,
there's just something about the way talks where,
you know,
if someone was talking to you in your home in that same way,
you would think they are absolutely insane.
Like if you had someone over your house and you're having a conversation with
them and they spoke the way Obama speaks when he's addressing the nation,
he would go,
well,
I got a fucking crazy person in my house.
Like even if they were just addressing your family,
if it was just one person standing at the table and he said,
hey Brock,
would you,
uh,
you know,
give us thanks for this meal that were about this half.
He gave this presidential type speech.
The way he's communicating with these long pauses and weird affectations of his
voice.
He'd be like,
who is this fucking guy?
But he's,
he's
not as bad as w where it really gets crazy for me.
It's when it,
it becomes a full or a tutorial or rhetorical performance.
I mean,
someone like,
you know,
Martin Luther King junior or you know,
or a a,
a preacher,
somebody who's just going for it in the Stentorian way of just,
it's going to be big and it's going to be dramatic and I'm going to make you
cry.
And,
and now obviously it's incredibly effective.
You know,
you see,
you know,
MLK speeches and that's something very powerful is going on there and he's
standing in front of whatever it was,
400,000 people.
Um,
so it's a big moment and you wouldn't,
it wouldn't be the same if he was just conversational,
but,
um,
you know,
it,
it begins to look kind of Hitlarian.
I mean,
Hitler was the ultimate example of this,
to look at Hitler,
give a speech.
I don't know how anyone thought the guy was saying.
I mean,
it just,
it looks,
it's so,
so far from the,
the,
the normal,
the norms of human conversation that it's just,
it,
it seems pathological to me.
I mean,
I don't know German.
I don't,
I don't know exactly.
So I'm not,
when I watch him speak,
I'm,
you know,
reading the subtitles and I'm getting his vibe and there's,
I'm not getting the exact exactly what a German would have gotten,
but I don't,
it's,
it's just,
I'm not comfortable there.
There's something,
um,
that there's,
there's a dishonesty to the performance there that I feel like no matter how,
how,
no matter what the content,
like the p one,
the performance variable becomes,
I frankly get this,
even with people like MLK where it's,
it's,
I mean I recognize that the words are beautiful.
I recognized that he's delivering it well,
but there's a subtle dishonesty to the communication because it is a
performance.
It's not,
and I'm not coming,
you know,
as a speaker,
I,
you know,
I tried to speak,
and this is one reason why I would never be a great speaker,
but I try to be as conversational as possible.
I just cause,
cause internally to,
to inhabit it.
I,
I'm only comfortable feeling like I'm actually talking to a person.
So if,
if it's,
if it's just you or if it's a thousand people,
I mean maybe my,
maybe that situation is going to dictate a subtle changes in the way I speak,
but it's going to be going to be pretty close in terms of how I speak.
And so it's,
um,
cause I just can't,
the moment I started to,
you know,
ape Paraclese,
I begin to feel dishonest and yeah,
it's weird because it's so effective.
You know,
Jay Leno,
when he would a practice his monologue for the tonight show,
he would go to the comedy and Magic Club every Sunday night.
And uh,
it was like a regular show he would do there.
And on Sunday night when you would go to the comedy magic club and read these,
uh,
bits,
then he would try out for the weeks monologue.
He would do them dead like monotone.
The reason why I did it,
he goes,
I didn't want to add any extra pizzazz to the jokes to sell them.
He goes,
I just want to know whether they stood on their own right.
And that was how we found out whether or not it was an actual funny idea or
whether or not it was just his master showmanship ability that was getting it
across.
And I think that's what you get when you get a Hitler or a Martin Luther King is
like,
it's not just their words,
it's just there's an energy behind them that's captivating,
that can be in the terms of like a guy like Martin Luther King.
It can enhance the speech to the point where I have a dream.
It's like one of the greatest speeches in human history.
And one of the reasons why it's such a great speech is not just because he said
it,
but imagine if the same speech was read by Noam Chomsky,
you'd fucking fall asleep halfway into it,
you know?
Yeah.
You know,
there's,
there's no question something would be lost,
but I s part of it is,
uh,
I know part of it is the context.
I mean,
just,
just being in front of an audience that large and a live audience and just the
necessity of having to have your,
even though,
even though you're miked,
there's the sense that your voice,
it needs to carry.
You know,
even though it's being aided by a mic,
he's,
it's appropriate to be belting it out over,
over the heads of the audience.
Whereas if,
if you were just in a room with 10 people,
you know,
blasting,
I have a dream that loud would just be,
you'd be,
you'd be carted off.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
If you were right here,
just you and I are in a podcast started breaking out in that loud time for naked
choke guys,
nuts call the cops.
Kennison who started out as a reverend,
uh,
used to break out into it on stage sometimes as a part of his performance that
he would,
uh,
he would say,
then they asked me,
Sam,
have you had to do it?
If you had to go back,
have you had to teach the word of God?
Could you do it?
Do you have it in you?
It's the Holy Spirit alive.
And he would go into this thing and it was so compelling.
They're just like,
whatever it is about human beings.
When we see someone who speaks with his dynamic power,
this passion,
this ability to project words,
it's so,
it's so impressive.
Yeah.
It's just because most of us can't do it or it's part of it,
I think in a part of it is,
there's just something about us that like,
like the reason why you can get hypnotized by a fucking watch swinging in front
of your face.
There's something about certain actions are either hypnotic,
certain patterns of speaking that are hypnotic,
oddly captivating.
Oddly enough.
Yeah.
You know,
even just,
just eye contact.
This is something I write about briefly in the book.
It's a,
um,
one thing you get in the spiritual world with gurus of various flavors is you
get this commitment to really intense eye contact.
Tom Cruise.
Yeah.
Oh,
sorry.
It was going to say about Tom Cruise when he talks to you.
He's like,
yeah,
well,
interesting sound.
It is a Scientology thing.
Yeah.
Just locks up on you and you just want to believe him.
But nobody's is incredibly intrusive and it's,
but it,
there,
I mean,
there's,
there's every version of it.
There are people who are just non neurotic.
They're not,
they don't feel any impulse to look away,
right?
They're not,
and they're not uncomfortable making silent eye contact with somebody.
They don't,
they're not constantly throwing their words into the space because they're
uncomfortable.
And yet they're just,
they're just available and they're just looking at you and they're,
their attention is free because they're not,
they're not busy.
They're not worried that,
that,
you know,
the,
about what you're thinking about them.
And they're just,
they're just so,
they're just presence.
And these people can tend to make a highly,
unusually intense eye contact,
um,
which is to say,
you know,
completely unbroken eye contact.
And then there's,
you know,
psychopaths to do it.
And it's a real power game where it's just,
you know,
they're just,
they're not there.
They're running something.
Um,
uh,
they have a very different agenda,
but they're also comfortable,
you know,
I fucking you and,
and,
and just,
um,
uh,
doing it from a place of,
of aggression.
Uh,
but it's a,
it was interesting when I first,
when I got into meditation and early on,
this is,
you know,
I was 20,
21 and got really into meditation.
And,
um,
uh,
this,
this is a period where I was doing a lot of psychedelics.
And one of the experiences you've probably had on psychedelics is the,
the amazing experience.
And just looking into somebody's eyes on acid or mushrooms and just having that
just open a kind of an inner landscape of profundity or seeming profundity where
you're just,
you know,
you can just be staring into someone's eyes silently for an eternity or what
seems like an eternity.
And,
um,
what often happens to people is that,
that after having experiences like this,
then looking into people's eyes can become a way of really,
uh,
of,
of kind of activating that state of mind where you,
you know,
you just being committed to looking into people's eyes and never look in a way
can be a way of sort of introducing that sort of liquid psychedelic experience,
you know,
interpersonally.
And I was sort of into that to,
to uh,
uh,
for a while and um,
so I was kind of walking through life,
you know,
like,
like guess Tom Cruise does basically.
Yeah,
just,
just like,
exactly.
Just never just like,
oh,
I'm just going to go with it.
You,
let's see where this goes and I'm just never going to look away from anyone ever
again.
And you,
you get,
you start having it's,
it's intrusive and I stopped doing it.
You,
you start having unusual experiences.
The first thing you do is you discover everyone else is doing that for whatever
reason.
So all of the psychopaths and the Scientologists and all,
everyone comes out of the woodwork because there,
there's some number of people walking around earth at this moment who are
playing that game,
who are just all,
it's like you look into their eyes and it's just,
I lock for as long as you're going to stay and you never,
they're never going to look away.
And so whether it's a Barista at Starbucks or whether it's just somebody who is,
you know,
50 feet across the room at a party and he make eye contact,
they're not going to be the first one to look away.
And so you get into these really weird encounters.
And I had this,
I remember this one party I went to where I was sitting,
sitting on a couch.
I looked across the room and there was this guy looking at me and I
probably,
you know,
40 feet between us.
And he looked at me and I looked at him and then it was just like war of the
warlocks,
you know,
it's like
neither of us were going to look away,
right.
And it just be that.
And I was doing a lot of meditation and I was,
uh,
you know,
I had,
it was probably,
uh,
taking acid once a month,
you know,
so I was,
I was pretty tuned up for this kind of game where it's just like,
I,
you know,
I was not,
I had no problem making eye contact with some strange guy,
you know,
40 feet away.
Um,
and after a certain point he jumped up and kind of raced over to me and,
you know,
we had a problem.
He's like,
what the fuck are you doing?
[inaudible] he,
there was like a real s so what I was doing was so intrusive,
you,
but he,
he had his own game going because he,
you know,
he didn't look away.
Right.
He was available for it.
But in any case,
when you walk through life like this,
you discover that there are a lot of people doing this for,
for whatever reason.
And it's,
it's a,
you definitely have unusual
counters with strangers.
A train.
Once when I was a kid,
um,
I was probably like 16 or 17 years old and Boston and uh,
it was some guy and we were sitting across from each other and we looked,
looked at each other and,
and he looked at me and he gave me like a little extra look to get me to look
away like a little extra.
And I didn't.
And I was like,
what's going on here?
And for whatever reason I don't,
it wasn't like a,
a conscious practice.
I just decided I wasn't going to look away.
I just would act of defiance being a teenager and he progressively got more and
more angry.
And then my level of stress raised up to the point where like,
am I going to have to fight this whole motherfucker?
Like we're gonna,
we're gonna have to go at it because we're staring at each other.
And then finally something happened.
One of us broke,
but we didn't have a confrontation.
But I remember the intensity of this lock with me and this guy looking at each
other and he just fucking look like,
fuck,
are you looking at,
I don't remember how it resolved,
but it did.
There was no,
there was no communication,
there was nothing.
But I remember very specifically thinking like,
this is so weird.
All we're doing this obviously some aggression being displayed here.
We're looking at each other in the eyes.
You,
Ms. Guy just don't want to turn away.
And I've decided I'm not going to turn away for whatever reason.
And here it's like a moment that I remember it to this day,
you know,
30 years later,
it's still in my head for no reason at all.
Just me in this fucking guy looking at each other on the train.
It's,
um,
well it is very primal thing and it just is a,
it's a,
a biological transgression.
I mean,
we are,
you know,
we are primates,
so you do this to a macaque or you know,
any,
a monkey or Ayp and they,
they're not into it,
you know,
you're walking in.
Um,
I remember I was in Nepal a lot and there are these,
um,
uh,
monkeys that basically now mug people.
They're so used to just showing up with their troop and demanding food that
you're just,
you,
you know,
you need to just throw your throw whatever you've got in your hand on the
ground.
But the,
um,
yeah,
mate,
you're making eye contact is a,
with a,
with a primate.
Um,
uh,
not even just a prime and a dog is a very,
it's an aggressive thing to do.
Uh,
but it's interesting to be with someone who I studied with a lot of great
meditation masters who spent years in on retreat,
some of them decades on retreat doing nothing but meditate.
Some of them spending years meditating just on the compassion.
And when you're with someone like that you want,
then it's a very,
it's a very different vibe obviously.
And,
and the,
the,
um,
what you're getting from that,
that kind of eye contact is just a fundamental freedom from
kind of the neurotic self program that everyone's running.
I mean,
you can,
you can meet someone who you feel like is just there.
They don't have a problem.
They're not there.
They wish you nothing but well and they're not,
um,
they don't want anything from you.
You know,
they know that they're not,
they're not worried about what you think of them.
Their attention is free enough to just,
it just see what you need and what you want.
And it's a,
it's a very,
um,
it's a very freeing
thing to recognize in someone as being possible to just see someone who's just
dropped down to a level of non neurosis that you recognize you just haven't,
haven't experienced in yourself and their,
their,
their surrogates for this.
And there's this sort of their artifacts which are confusing to people because
now they say in any situation like this or power dynamics where when you are
just the,
when you're the guy on stage or you're the guy in the,
in the powerful role or you're the celebrity or whatever it is,
you're kind of free to be non neurotic when everyone else is dancing around
being neurotic.
You know,
when someone's busy,
like trying to not be not spazz meeting Joe Rogan,
you often are just free just to be a nice guy.
Who's who,
who um,
it's,
I mean,
I don't know if this is true of you and maybe it's not true all the time,
but it's,
it's,
you can be sort of empowered by a role,
uh,
and it's kind of liberating and then you can find yourself in another context.
It's,
this goes to the first point we made about different states of self.
You can find yourself in another context where you're just trying,
you're not Joe Rogan the celebrity or you're not the guy who's on who was on
stage.
You're just someone trying to get something done with somebody else who's not
taking you seriously.
And you can feel all of your sort of normal level of neurosis kick in cause
you're not empowered in that situation.
There's nothing about the frame around the situation that is making you the
center of attention or making anyone defer to what you were saying or,
um,
and so contexts can,
I mean,
you can,
you can prop up a totally fake guru who has no skills at all.
Who's got who,
who's just,
and this experiment has been done,
I think I'm James Randy just created a fake guru,
I think it was in Australia and New Zealand.
He got some suitably mysterious looking Latin guy and called him the amazing
whatever and set him up as a,
a fully enlightened,
you know,
man from,
the Andes or whatever,
who had spent 20 years in a cave and,
and now it was going to deliver his wisdom to the world.
And they put out,
you know,
put up ads and they convene,
500 people and they gave this guy in earpiece and they were feeding him lines,
uh,
and every,
you know,
he,
he transformed every bit about his life and that room to some degree.
And it was actually a documentary.
This Kumari I don't know if it's all US hilarious.
Is that on the same guy?
No,
different guy.
Different Guy,
but same,
same thought experiment.
What is it called again?
Komara yeah,
well worth seeing.
It's hearing great things about it.
It's one of those things,
it's always on my to list and I never get
around to,
yeah,
that was hilarious.
The guy does a great job because he's,
he's Indian and he,
he,
he speaks perfect English,
you know,
he just,
he just lays it down.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
Well this is also the,
the,
the sexual attraction thing.
The eye contact,
that context.
Whereas you can't make eye contact with a woman like that and just lock eyes
with her without her thinking you want to have sex with her or was she locks
eyes with you without her thinking that you want to have or you know,
the opposite.
Right.
When that it's only in a gay sense w with two men,
you know,
like the,
the thing about looking at someone like it's almost like you're giving them the
green light.
Like,
I'm interested in you,
I'm looking at you,
I'm interested in you or I'm threatening you or I am challenging.
You are your position of dominance or whatever the fuck it is.
When you're looking locking eyes,
it's very different when it's intersexual.
When it's male to female.
Well it can,
it can be just as intrusive.
Yes.
Yeah.
More so because especially male to woman,
you know,
because of a of a guy is locking eyes with another guy.
It's weird,
but it's,
it's not like,
Oh God,
this guy has got to fuck me.
You know,
between two guys,
you get that monkey dance of,
you know,
what are you looking at?
What are you looking at?
Then it becomes,
do we have to fight kind of.
Whereas with a man to woman,
it's just,
it's intrusive.
I think of the guy is not picking up whatever cues of disinterest or,
you know,
the boundary setting are there and he's just staring and that's just,
it's just uncomfortable given,
uh,
given that,
you know,
women are the targets of,
of,
uh,
sexual violence and just,
you know,
harassment.
So freewill.
Yeah.
Let's get you have to get to,
because we only have an hour left.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
this is something that is perplexing,
confusing,
hotly debated is their free will and you will,
we will
probably say no.
Yeah,
I have said no much to the consternation of many a certain people,
a philosophers like Dan Dennett who,
who,
um,
I collided with on this issue.
Uh,
even though,
um,
it didn't have to be as,
as unpleasant as it turned out to be.
How did,
why was it unpleasant?
Well,
what he,
yeah,
I mean,
what happened is I,
so I wrote this very short book freewill,
uh,
which was actually if there was a short section in my book,
the moral landscape,
which in which I laid out my,
my argument against free will and it got so much attention and people found it
so interesting and,
and disturbing and um,
it was clearly just one.
It would just,
you know,
I mean,
it might've been only 10 pages in the book,
but it was something that just people wanted more of.
And so what I did is I took those 10 pages and I could blew them up into a
hundred page but still very short book that you could read in an hour,
an hour and a half and published it as,
as a freewill.
And then Dan Dennett,
who is a very well known and very smart philosopher who's a colleague and friend
of mine and,
and you know,
comrade in arms or on the whole religion issue.
He and I have a,
along with Richard Dawkins and Christopher Hitchens have often been talked about
in the same sentence as,
you know,
the four horsemen,
uh,
you know,
or the,
the,
the new atheists.
And,
and so we've been,
you know,
we are,
we are aligned on many,
many questions and certainly virtually all the questions related to the
collision between science and religion knew he,
he and I make the same noises on,
um,
and,
but free,
free will has always been a topic of his that he's,
he spent a lot of time on and he has a different take on it.
And it's a take that I'm really not a fan of.
And rather than,
uh,
rather than fully engage his view in,
in my book,
uh,
because I actually,
the truth is I think his view on free will,
which has,
which is called compatible ism,
is the argument that that free will is compatible with determinism.
It's,
it,
it's,
it's uh,
you don't have to,
even if,
even if we're in a,
in a universe where all causality is just,
we're kind of running like clockwork,
uh,
we including every influence on the human brain and you know,
everything that's giving rise to thoughts and decisions and behavior of,
it's all just a machine that's kind of running out from the big bang to the heat
death of the universe.
Um,
free will is compatible with that determinism.
And uh,
so then he,
he has a fleshed out his compatible ism.
He's not the only compatiblist,
but he's,
he's the most famous at this point.
He's fleshed out his compatible as a,
in a couple of books.
Now I think compatible ism is just actually,
it's just changing the subject.
It's not,
it's redefining.
Freewill is something that is,
that doesn't actually track what people think they have.
And in my view,
he's just not grappling with the illusion that,
that,
that can be penetrated here and it should be penetrated here.
So I didn't really want to engage his,
I mentioned his books.
I started,
I sort of,
I mentioned them only to kind of put them on the shelf as,
you know,
this is not,
this doesn't really get at the issue and this,
you know,
pissed him off frankly.
And He,
um,
he thought he was being,
you know,
in his defense,
I think he thought he was being very,
uh,
diplomatic and measured and a responsible in how he engaged me.
Uh,
and,
uh,
what he did is he wrote a review of a free,
I think he waited like a year,
but then he wrote a review of the book,
which I published on my website.
But,
um,
it was a very hard hitting,
but in my view,
misguided and confused review of my book.
And so then I responded and,
you know,
he didn't like my response and then that was,
that's kind of where we left it.
But it was a kind of a very long review that,
that,
um,
made a lot of noise,
uh,
to not much effect in,
in my view.
And then then I responded with a very long review where I hit back probably a
little too hard.
Um,
and it's one of those problems you get into when you're just writing rather than
having a conversation.
So what I,
what I urged him to do,
and this is the reason why my review came off as so frustrated and people can
read,
people can find all this on my blog,
my review,
I published his,
his review on my blog and an af,
I forget what the title was there,
but you'll can easily find on my blog.
And then my review,
it was called the,
the marionettes lament.
And then I,
that was my response to his review of freewill.
Um,
but the problem was I told him,
I said,
Dan,
we should,
we should just have a public conversation about this.
This is the,
this is the old,
it's only in conversation that you can correct for somebody else's
misunderstandings in real time.
And you start to say something that is miss characterizing my view.
And I'll say,
no,
that's not it.
Actually this.
And then,
and then you get,
you can keep getting back on track it more or less effortlessly.
But what happens is when you,
when you have these,
when you're writing and you're having these mutual,
you know,
3000 or 10,000 word volleys where I'm just going to lay it out,
what's,
you know,
what's totally wrong with your worldview.
And in the course of doing that,
I'm going to make 15 huge mistakes that,
you know,
you could have,
you could have corrected in real time.
But now I'm committed to them because I wrote a page on each,
you know,
and then,
and then we just go back and forth.
And so that's,
so I really urged him to have a debate with me or a conversation and he didn't
want to do that.
And then,
um,
he,
uh,
he wrote this review and I,
I said,
okay.
And he hadn't probably showed me the review before I put it,
before he was going to publish,
it was gonna publish this,
publish it in a,
on a website that was far more obscure than my blog.
Um,
which he did.
But I,
I,
I co publish it on my blog,
but I said,
before you publish this,
just let me,
let me make this a conversation.
Let me take this text and interrupt you.
You know,
you,
you can say anything you want to say,
but let me just build in some mechanism where you can correct for it.
Cause like they're there 10 places here where you're misunderstanding me.
And so let me just let me turn this into a conversation.
And it was no,
go there.
And so then he's,
he just finally published it and I said,
okay,
well,
fine.
Um,
so in any case,
people can,
can witness the collision.
They're on my blog.
But the,
the basic case against freewill is this,
it's two fold.
One is that,
and again,
it's the,
it's the OBC verse of this sense of self.
It's the,
as the other side of the coin where you,
you feel like you're a thinker of thoughts,
you feel like you're the,
the,
the author of intentions,
you feel like you are a subject and
commensurate with that feeling is the sense that you are in a position to do
what it is you do to decide to do.
I can decide to lift my left hand or I can decide to lift my right hand and I
can deliberate between the two.
And I can have reasons for one or reasons for the other.
And um,
I'm in the driver's seat,
I really am.
And then you tea and,
and so that's,
that's where everyone's starting.
Uh,
the problem with that is objectively,
we know that everything that you're consciously aware of all your thoughts and
your intentions and your impulses and your impulses to,
to resist those impulses.
I mean,
well,
however,
however your,
whatever's coming up for you,
we know that's all proceeded by events in your nervous system of which you're
not aware in which you didn't create.
And the,
and the state of your brain in this moment,
it's in every sense is the product of variables that you are not responsible
for.
You didn't pick your parents,
you didn't pick your jeans,
you didn't sculpt your jeans,
you didn't pick the environment in which your genome was going to be expressed.
You didn't pick the way that your interaction with the world and other people
sculpted the micro structure of your brain.
So as to give you the brand new,
have you didn't pick the number of receptors you've ha have of every type.
But every sin APPS,
he didn't pick all the charges and eh,
that are currently in place in your brain at this moment.
You haven't,
you haven't created your neurophysiology and yet your neurophysiology is going
to give rise to every next thought and intention that shows up for you.
And so,
so,
and we know that if you do an experiment,
like you put someone in a,
in a,
uh,
neuro imaging device,
whether it's,
whether it's EEG or whether it's a MRI or,
um,
and you image there their neural activity in real time.
And you have a very simple choice between pushing the left button or pushing the
right button.
We can predict before the person is aware of having committed to right or left,
whether they're going to go right or left.
And we know that that's,
that ability to predict is only going to become more fine grain.
So that,
so that if you take away as,
and again,
someone like Dan Dennett has a story about why this doesn't matter,
right?
But,
um,
and the truth is it actually doesn't matter because even if we couldn't predict
it matters in this in a sense that it's,
it's very persuasive to people that,
you know,
if I can predict what you're going to do before you are aware of what you're
going to do,
well then the basis for freewill seems to go out the window.
Okay.
Two things.
One,
how can you,
so,
but for instance,
just notice this moment.
So let's say I had written down on a piece of paper,
the next sentence you're going to speak,
right?
So I had verbatim what's going to come out of your mouth now and you just so you
know,
you start your side of the conversation and I just hold up this pad and you see
that I have everything that is just now occurring you just to current to you to
say that would be pretty persuasive to you,
that you're not running a freewill program over there.
Right?
Right.
And so that's the intuition that I'm trying to get at so that if we can predict
what you're going to think before you think it,
where is your freewill?
Because you're,
you're,
you are going to be,
you're thinking it is,
is the,
is this is the basis of your sense of free will in the first place.
You feel like you are offering this next thought.
You feel like you're,
do you feel like it's a,
but if I could show you that we knew what you were going to do before you did
it,
that would erode this sense that you're free to do otherwise.
How in what sense could you have done otherwise?
If I can hold up this piece of paper and show you that you were committed to
saying what you were using.
The sounds a dishonest argument though,
because you can't do that.
Well,
no,
but we can do it in a very simple paradigm,
but you can,
you can predict whether or not someone's going to lift their right hand or their
left hand based on FM Ri.
But how do you know when someone has decided or not decided?
Like what,
what is that point of decision?
What does that mean?
I mean,
if there's decisive sort of a thing like lifting your left hand or your right
hand.
Like if we just have an FMRI attached to your head and say randomly,
just every 30 seconds,
I want you to lift your left hand to your right hand.
Right?
How do you know when a person has decided?
Yeah,
well a good question.
It's,
it's,
and it's a little difficult to operationalize or make design an experiment
around.
But what they've done is they created a clock which made it,
and this has been done in a few different ways,
but they,
in each one of these experiments,
they could essentially create a clock that made it very easy for someone to
discriminate time.
So isn't,
it wasn't just what like watching an ordinary clock,
but it could be,
let's say a bunch of letters and numbers kind of streaming in front of you.
You know,
or you're getting,
you're being presented with a bunch of different letters,
numbers,
and um,
I'm asking you,
you're free to decide.
You can take as long as you want,
you know,
you're going to choose left or right.
And I'm not forcing you to go at any particular time.
Uh,
and you're just watching the letters and numbers and all.
Your only job is to tell me what letter a number or number was present the
moment you were,
you decided,
right.
So you as you're watching,
you know,
k and x and four and seven,
and so all these different numbers and letters that are easily discriminated,
coming,
appearing on a screen and you're just waiting to decide and you're thinking,
oh,
maybe I'll go laugh,
maybe I'll go,
right,
I'm free to do whatever I want.
And uh,
you know,
I'm just going to,
I'm going to wait this out a little bit,
but all right,
I'm going to go.
Right.
And the moment you feel that you're committed,
you recall what number or a letter you were looking at,
and then you tell the experimenter afterward I was looking at k a k was on the
screen when I was committed.
Now what's,
you might think this is not so compelling when the time interval is very brief
and some of these experiments,
that distance was like half a second,
right?
But with this recent FMRI experiment,
the distance stretched out to like five seconds,
five to seven seconds.
So that,
so that the,
the,
the activity,
uh,
that was,
was inclining a person to go right as opposed to left,
was building up subconsciously for that long.
So that at a certain point the person died.
All right,
I have decided,
but the data show that we could have predicted that with great accuracy five to
seven seconds earlier.
See,
but that's for lying on a person.
Being honest about when they decided that it seems,
it seems rather crude.
And it also seems to conflict with what we were talking about earlier with,
which is the idea of controlling your thoughts,
the idea of getting to a point in your mind where you are,
uh,
essentially in control of which way you're,
your brain goes right.
Whether you adhere to one pattern of thinking or another.
And if you're,
you're talking about something as crude as lifting a left hand or right hand
deciding when to do so based on whatever idea that pops into your head.
That seems like an incredibly crude way to argue that there's no free will.
Well,
it's not a,
again,
let me,
let me just be clear about this.
It's an,
it's a very interesting experiment.
I agree.
It's crude.
Except I think that with this time interval it becomes,
there's less of a concern that the person's judgment about when they decided
we'll be off by enough so as to to make it a,
an invalid experiment.
But I don't think it's enough to satisfy me.
But let me just tell you,
it's just,
there's no,
nothing hinges on this because even if your,
the decision that the,
the,
the neural activity in the brain that that gave you the decision and you,
you are subjective feeling of having decided,
even if those were coincident,
even if there was no time lag,
right,
it's still is coming out of nowhere in a sense for free for you subjectively.
You're still not in control of it and you're still,
it's still being caused by events that you didn't cause.
So again,
you didn't pick your genetics and you didn't pick any,
you didn't pick out,
you know,
so it's like,
and the real illusion here or mode,
what most people think is that there's a very strong,
a very strong subjective case for freewill.
We all know we have,
but we all feel it.
We're all living it.
And yet it's very difficult to map on to third person.
Reality is that it's very,
it's very difficult to map onto the physical world.
Um,
that,
that is not the situation from my point of view.
I think it,
it is very difficult to map on to,
in fact impossible to map onto the physical world.
There's no way to describe the way causes can propagate in the universe so as to
make this idea of freewill makes sense.
Because either they're determined or they're random or there's some combination
of both and no combination of determinism and randomness gets you free will,
determinism doesn't get your freewill because you're just a machine.
Randomness doesn't get your freewill because you're just a machine that's
throwing dice occasionally.
Um,
so,
but,
but the,
the feeling is that,
and this is the feeling that I think Dan Dennett has,
there's this very compelling,
subjective sense of freewill that we somehow have to make room for.
And I'm saying we don't have to make room for it because if you look closely
enough,
you don't actually even feel it.
It's not even,
you don't even feel that you have the free freedom that you think you feel.
Because if you just look at how thoughts arise,
if you just look at it,
if I just pay attention to how I get to the end of this sentence,
I don't know how I get to the end of the sentence.
He in,
in,
in the,
in the cases where I fail to get to the end of the sentence where I miss a word
I,
where I'm the speak in a way that's not grammatically correct.
Each one of those hiccups is a mystery to me.
Fun subjectively and no doubt it's caused by some,
uh,
some events in my brain that,
that could be understood if we were scanning my brain.
Um,
but subjectively
it's always a surprise.
But successfully finding the word you're looking for is also in some sense of
surprise.
It's also something that you're not actually offering.
And when you,
when you look at why you choose one word over another,
you know,
you,
you say
thing like,
um,
uh,
you know,
there's a,
there's a consistency between,
uh,
this story and that story.
And then you say,
well,
why did I choose the word consistency?
You know,
there,
there are other synonym,
there are other words that mean consistency that I could have used.
I could have said there's a harmony between this story and that story,
um,
that,
that is subjectively mysterious and was determined by events in your brain that
you are not responsible for.
And so if I,
in a very simple experiment,
if I say to you,
what are you going to think of next?
You know,
so your net,
your next thought.
So I'm going to ask you to think of a city.
He city.
Chicago.
Okay.
So you thought of Chicago now perhaps it,
and then were there other cities that,
that kind of percolated there that were vying for inclusion and then you,
you decide on Chicago?
Yeah,
it could be.
Okay.
But were you consciously aware of,
Oh,
I just came here.
Okay.
I just randomly picked one.
So Chicago now of all the cities,
you know the name of,
right?
You Pick Chicago now they're all the,
there's a bunch of cities that you don't know the names of.
So you couldn't have picked them.
Right,
so you're not,
you were not free to pick them.
But then there's,
you know,
probably hundreds of cities who,
who,
whose names you recognize and who would,
you could have potentially you could have said,
you know,
Budapest,
you could've said Cairo,
he could've said Paris,
but those cities didn't occur to you for whatever reason.
Now,
so,
so the question is that this is where,
and this is as free of choices I think you're ever going to make.
The question is where are you free to think what didn't occur to you?
To think where you for really free to say Paris.
Now you in some,
in Dan Dennett sense,
you were free to say Paris,
you had the item not holding a gun to your head saying don't say Paris.
You were,
you could have in some other situation similar to this thought of Paris,
but for whatever reason Paris was not in the cards for you.
And it was not the based on the state of your,
based on the inputs that had happened earlier today,
based on whatever variables could control how this experiment was going to run.
You thought Chicago and you didn't think Paris.
Now
in a deterministic universe you were not free to think Paris and in a,
in and the,
if we add randomness,
it doesn't give you the freedom of will that you think you have what the cause
the freedom of will people think they have is they are free to,
to have done otherwise they could have done otherwise.
You know,
you could have you.
So what does it mean to say you could have said Paris,
right?
You said Chicago,
we can't take that back.
But your belief in freewill entails the belief that,
you know,
if we,
if we rewind the movie of our lives right now,
if we just go back in this conversation a few minutes and Sam says,
think of a city
leaving everything else the same as the university.
Exactly.
In the same state.
I could have said Paris and there's no reason.
There's no reason scientifically to think that you could have because that would
main,
the universe would have had to have been in a different state.
But are we not getting trapped in my new she here because is it not a
combination of determinism and randomness?
Because of course there's determinism,
of course there's,
there's certain events that have taken place in my life that I can't change.
Of course there's jeans,
there's life experiences.
Uh,
there's,
I have experienced in Chicago,
it's a city I love,
so it comes up to my mind pretty quickly.
But it's also randomness because I just went to Chicago.
I just picked a name.
But that doesn't apply to my life.
And I think when you talk about free will,
when most people talk about free will,
they,
they think about actions in terms of their life.
Like if you have an opportunity to cheat on your taxes,
but you think it's morally wrong and you don't want to go to jail,
isn't it not freewill to look at your tax form and make the decision to be
correct?
Like isn't that freewill is,
and they're not free will.
And we'll all listen to control your thoughts as we were discussing earlier.
Let me address that question cause he,
cause it seems so this can all seem very happy
attract and academic and of no use to anyone.
And what I argue in my book is that it admitting that free will is an illusion
actually does have some important consequences.
They're not.
The kind of consequences that people worry about is not that you have no basis
to be a better person or to change your life or to you to add,
to make efforts to improve yourself.
That all remains intact.
But it does change our ethical views of good and evil in some important ways.
And so we can maybe table that for the moment or,
or maybe we'll get to it,
but the,
you look at it.
So you look at an,
at your effort to be a better person.
And so your effort not to cheat on your taxes or to cheat on your wife or to
cheat on your diet,
um,
let's make it very simple.
You're on a diet and you're,
you've decided you're going to go carb free for the next week,
but then see you,
you come in here and someone's,
you know,
giving you some donuts and you're tempted to eat a,
but then you have that moment of a tug of war with yourself and you say,
no,
I'm,
I've decided to go carb free.
um,
I'm going to toss these,
that back and forth.
Now you,
they're there,
you've been in that situation many times before.
Sometimes you cave in and eat the donut.
Sometimes you're just,
you've got a will of steel and you don't eat the doughnut.
But in each,
in each case,
the difference there,
your,
your ability to resist,
your inability to resist your,
your,
you just,
you know,
w w which part of you wins in that circumstance is also being born of variables
in your nervous system that you didn't author,
that you didn't control.
I mean,
this is like a tiny,
and if you could,
and if you could understand them perfectly,
right,
if you could,
if you could see all the causality,
you would see that you were not in control of that at that moment.
Your control,
you had exactly as much willpower as you had in that moment.
And not,
uh,
not,
Adam Moore and,
and you can't take cra and so,
but what that doesn't mean,
that doesn't mean that willpower is irrelevant.
That doesn't mean that training is irrelevant.
So I was like for,
you know,
if I want a black belt in Jujitsu,
I've got to train in Jujitsu.
I can't just sit back and see what happens.
Right?
I can't just wait to see if I get a black belt or your decision to train,
you're saying absolutely not.
It's part of the call,
but it is part of the causality.
My decision to train will be the proximate cause of my going into a school and
training.
My desire to,
to get a black belt is going to be the proximate cause in each moment of,
uh,
of my making it a priority to train my,
making the effort to train my,
my,
uh,
getting over injury,
my ignoring injuries when I,
when I otherwise would be cowed by them.
Whatever.
All,
all of those,
your,
your intentions and your efforts and your desires are just as causal and as
important as you think they are.
I mean,
they,
they are,
you are driven by desire and you're an effort does matter.
And,
and training has an effect.
All of that's true,
but,
and so,
so you can't,
where people get confused is they think that determinism is the same thing as
fatalism.
Whereas if everything's just going to happen as it happens,
well then I don't have to do anything.
Right.
You know,
I'm not,
so I'm just gonna see if I got a black belt,
you know,
I just not,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna make any efforts because if I,
if I'm destined to get a black belt,
you know,
someone's going to give me one.
Right.
That makes no sense.
Right,
right.
If I'm destined to learn Chinese,
I'm just going to start speaking Chinese.
So how's that?
Not a combination of determinism and maybe the momentum of your past
determination,
which is based on a conscious thought,
a conscious thought to decide to be disciplined,
to sought,
decided to have a very specific diet,
to write down goals.
I mean is that not freewill in some sense because isn't the only way to truly
tell whether or not there is the ability to alter your events and your life and
your behavior based entirely on will when you have to have someone live the
exact same life with the exact same genetics,
exact same life experiences and confront the exact same circumstances and decide
or find out whether or not they act randomly or whether or not it's,
you can determine it.
Well that's the thing.
The thing is that,
so the first part of your question,
someone like Dan Dennett wants to say that is all we mean by free will.
The only thing you need for freewill is this effect of intention and training
and willpower.
And that's all anyone cares about anyway.
So the all rest of the stuff is irrelevant.
Determinism is irrelevant.
Um,
but
I don't,
I don't think that's true for,
for a few reasons.
The crucial piece is ethical.
So once you acknowledge that if someone
was,
it wasn't in exactly your situation,
given the same jeans and the same parents in the same environment,
same life influences,
same political circumstance,
same you just micro influences to his nervous system,
that person would make all the same choices you're making.
He'd have the exact same amount of willpower when he's confronted with a donut.
He'd fall off his diet the exact same number of times and in the same place as
you age,
the,
the movie of your life.
If replayed in your double on a,
on a nother planet,
that was exactly like this one would play out exactly the same and in the way.
And if randomness intrudes to make a different,
well then random.
This doesn't give you a freewill random,
it's just gives you randomness.
It's just,
if I just told you that,
that you're going to be exactly the same as your double and we can completely
predict your behavior.
A thousand years before you were even born.
Right.
Cause we've run this experiment before and we've tuned your genes and your and
your world.
Exactly.
You're just a computer simulation of your double,
right.
You're just going to run out exactly the same way so you've got no freewill.
But we are going to throw in a little randomness to make you,
you know,
I mean random events,
random but random events in your,
in your nervous system.
Yeah.
Random events in the world and random events and your w we can,
we can,
you can put the randomness wherever you want but so it's going to change your
life in various ways.
You're going to decide to eat the donut in one case and not in another and then
your,
your history,
your joint history with your,
your double is kind of diverge.
But that's not free will.
That's just,
you know,
if you knew that your decision to marry your wife as opposed to somebody else
was born of someone having thrown the dice in a lab somewhere,
you wouldn't,
you wouldn't ascribe that to freewill that you,
that would just be,
that would be a bizarre thing to dictate your,
your decision process.
So that's not what it,
when anyone means by free will.
So random,
this doesn't give you the freedom you think you have.
Um,
let me just say a bit about why this,
why,
why this is important.
Ethically,
it's just,
it's when you look at when we perceive good and evil in the world,
we look at people as agents really are the authors of their actions.
We really,
we,
we relate to people like they have free will.
And this seems to make ethical sense to us.
And it seems to,
it's definitely the basis for our,
our,
our impulse for vengeance and retributive justice and,
and the feeling that people really deserve to be punished.
You know,
bad people deserve what they get.
And I'm not arguing that punishment is never valid and there may be a role for
punishment that we,
we want to retain in our justice system.
But this idea of punishing people because they deserve it doesn't make a lot of
sense.
And the way to see that is to a way to see that one is you look at these cases
where you have someone like Charles Whitman who got on the the clock tower at
the University of Texas in 1964 I think it was,
or 66 and shot,
you know,
dozens of people.
I think he killed 14 and he killed his mom and his girlfriend for Kelly's mom
and his wife first.
And then he got on the clock tower and killed 14 people and injured like 30
people.
And this is just like pure evil,
right?
So this guy is,
if anyone deserves to be punished,
this guy does.
And,
and he was killed by the cops.
Um,
and he knew he was going to be killed by the cops and said,
and he had,
he had written essentially a suicide note.
Uh,
but you look at this behavior,
you think,
all right,
that's a stark,
as,
as stark,
as evil as we ever see.
A,
and this guy really is the cause of his actions.
But then you read a suicide note and he describes how he was overcome with rages
that he found inexplicably.
And he does,
did not know why he was killing his wife or his mom.
He loved them both,
but he just quit.
He just felt like he had to do it.
And he recommended the doctors do a postmortem on his brain because he knows
something's wrong with it.
And there's,
you know,
maybe they can find the reason why he did all these terrible things.
So they do an autopsy and they see that he's got a giant tumor and his
hypothalamus pressing on the Amygdala.
And that is a certainly a plausible place for it to be driving some rages in
somebody and to be undermining their,
their impulse control.
Um,
and so most people look at the story of Charles Whitman and they think,
all right,
this is an unlucky guy.
He had a brain tumor who was driven to act out on the basis of this brain tumor.
And that is not freewill,
right?
I mean this is the,
he's,
he was,
uh,
an unlucky puppet,
a and a victim of biology.
Now
the problem is a brain tumor really is just a special case of physical
causality.
And what I'm arguing is that if we fully,
if we had a perfect understanding of the brain,
if we could scan your brain at this moment and,
and,
and see every variable that influenced behavior as clearly and as compellingly
as a brain,
as a golf ball sized brain tumor,
right,
we would see that your behavior and your thoughts and your innermost desires and
your commitment to your diet and your love of Jujitsu and everything was just as
determined as Charles Whitman's rages by a a Glioblastoma.
Um,
and it all begins to look like a brain tumor.
It's a,
your,
your responsibility and your,
the fact that you're,
you're a mensch and you're a kind guy as opposed to a,
um,
a vindictive one.
All of those variables.
Again,
getting the,
that got,
uh,
that you inherited courtesy of genes and environment,
um,
which are the only influences we think you have.
Right?
And let the truth is,
even if you add an a soul,
you know,
you add an immortal Christian soul to the clockwork.
You didn't create your soul.
You know,
you,
you can't,
you can't take credit for the fact that you don't have the soul of a psychopath.
So whatever you add is in some sense a gift,
you know,
brain tumors,
souls,
jeans,
a cosmic ray bombardment,
any influence that,
and,
and if we could understand these influences,
clearly it would all begin to look like the Charles Whitman's brain tumor.
And if you add the rolling of dice,
you know,
you add some randomness to it that doesn't give you freedom.
That just gives you randomness.
See when I'm talking about randomness,
I'm not,
when you were saying like random events in the mind,
what I was saying is that the only way to truly determine whether or not someone
has the choice to make a decision one way or another is to have them live the
exact same life,
meaning the exact same amount of randomness,
the exact same events inside their mind and see whether or not conscious
decision making has any part in what you do.
Like the idea of free will is people are confronted with a scenario and they
decide what do I do here?
It's based on a lot of variables based on life experience.
It's certainly based on genetics.
It's certainly based on the environment that you grew up in,
the environment that you find yourself in.
But is there not a choice there?
Is there not a choice?
There's something that's going on in your mind where it's causing you to act in
one way or another.
And in my opinion,
the only way to know whether or not it is all determined by momentum and the
momentum of the past and your genetics is to have someone live the exact same
life and see what they do.
The exact same thing.
But you can exact same chemicals,
exact same diet,
the exact same,
no randomness at all.
And whether or not you decide to go one way or another,
okay?
But we know that every decision has to be proceeded by something,
right?
So it's,
and if you have,
you're going to take a scientific view of these things we know is proceeded by
neurophysiology,
right?
That's the same measure consciousness though.
If there is a consciousness.
So if there's a something in the mind,
right?
So,
so either whether you think what I'm arguing is that whether you think
consciousness is arising out of the information processing of the brain.
So it,
it's just,
it was what the brain and the mind is what the brain is doing or you think
consciousness is something else.
And even even something very spooky,
let's say it's Ectoplasm,
let's say it's a Christian soul,
whatever it is,
even in those,
even in that case of dualism,
you don't get free will.
You don't.
You just get,
you just get some spooky or causality that we don't,
we can't describe,
but it's still just coming out of the darkness for,
from,
from your point of view,
subjectively,
you don't know what you're gonna do next.
And when you do it,
you don't know.
We really don't know why you did it.
And if you have a story about why you did it,
you don't know why I make it.
So you can,
you can take a thousand years to choose between your right hand and your left
hand.
You could say it's going to be left,
is going to be right.
No,
no.
I rose my,
I,
I use my right yesterday.
I'm going to go for left you,
it doesn't matter how long you you take,
right?
You could take a literally a thousand years and you could have,
you could write a,
you know,
a million page document about what,
what it was like to deliberate over this,
but in the final moment where you decide,
you know what,
after all this,
I'm going to go with the right,
that there's,
there's a inherent mystery for subjectively speaking.
You don't know what tipped the balance and the sense that you did is just this
feeling of the,
I mean I it again,
it's,
it's the other side of this feeling of,
of,
of just being the thinker of your thoughts is the feeling of self.
It's the feeling of I as the feeling of I,
the feeling of May.
You're the one pushing the,
the,
the machine.
I understand what you're saying,
but the choice of a left hand or right hand is completely irrelevant.
There's no consequences one way.
That's just the simplest case.
But you can make it as big as you want.
What do,
whether I shoot,
shoot the intruder in my living room or not,
or whether or not you stick to a diet or whether or not you choose to be
inspired,
whether or not you get divorce.
Yeah,
well what?
What are those things?
I mean what is it that's causing those choices?
You're saying that it's all just genetics,
live experience of course,
random variables.
The mind that there is no self that makes a choice.
There is no self that the self,
even though the self is comprised of all these random variables like genetics,
life experiences,
the environment that you surround yourself with,
people that are in your life that influenced you.
These variables are the funnel through which all decisions are made and there is
no conscious choice.
There is no,
today I'm going to be a better person that you saying today I'm going to be a
better person,
is based entirely on a bunch of things that are outside of your control.
Right?
Right,
and yet there's that experience seemed semantic to me.
What will know that,
but there's that as well.
Here's why.
Why
it's not semantic in the sense that it's semantic.
It may be semantic and in how most people will live their lives most of the
time.
So you can still,
if you want to lose weight,
you still have to go on a diet,
right?
And if,
and if you want to stay on the Diet,
he still can't eat the doughnut,
right?
So you still have to have this negotiation with yourself.
But,
um,
and then all the,
all the things that,
that conventionally matter in that situation matters.
So it matters whether you keep donuts around or if you don't keep them around in
matters.
If your,
if your friends,
you know,
support you on your diet or they don't support you,
et cetera.
But here's where it changes.
Where,
so you think of an evil person like Uday Hussein,
who we've mentioned at the beginning,
um,
the,
the view of him as just pure evil,
worthy of being destroyed,
worthy.
If we could,
if we could have locked him,
you know,
it's worth,
he's worth,
it's worthy of punishment is anyone we could ever,
uh,
capture.
Um,
and that it makes sense to hate him,
that the,
the logic of hatred erodes here because it doesn't make sense to hate Charles
Whitman,
right?
Charles Whitman was unlucky.
You know,
that poor bastard had a brain tumor that caused him to kill his wife,
kill his mother,
and then kill a bunch of people and get killed himself,
right?
A very unlucky person.
Uday Hussein was also unlucky,
right?
So he,
and,
and you can see this if you just roll back the clock of his life,
right?
So when you look at him as a 40 year old,
he's the scariest psychopath you've ever seen when you look at him as a,
as a three year old,
okay.
He was a little boy who was going to become Uday Hussein.
He was a little boy who through no fault of his own,
had Saddam Hussein as a father,
right?
Imagine what that was like.
He has the genes he has,
right?
He has the,
the completely fucked up society that he has,
right?
And the honor culture and the,
and the crazy brother.
Right?
And,
um,
and he,
and you have to acknowledge,
given,
uh,
if whatever variables you want to include,
genes,
environment,
souls,
if you could trade places with him,
you get the same genes,
you get the same daddy,
you get the same environment,
you get the same s sole,
same ectoplasm,
whatever you want to put in to the,
to the box,
you would become Uday Hussein.
There's nothing,
there's nothing left,
right?
And,
and it's the sense that there's something left,
which is an illusion.
And,
but what I'm arguing is that this actually can become the basis for compassion
and for a wiser justice system.
And we have a justice system that's predicated on the notion of free will.
And we have,
we've locked up 13 year olds for their entire lives based on a sense that this
evil little bastard is really deserves what he gets.
I think we've done that because we want to protect everyone else from this evil
bastard.
I think the idea is not whether or not this person is free to make these
choices.
Well,
no,
we got there a day.
It is a sign,
you know,
know that the Supreme Court has actually said that our system is based on the
notion of free will and the determinism is hostile to any notion of retributive
justice.
So consciously as a matter of jurisprudence,
uh,
we think we are implementing a doctrine of free will.
Well then how do you indict people based on their responsibility for something?
What's exactly like,
um,
what we would do if grizzly bears were walking around outside.
So it's like,
it's,
so if we,
if I walk outside in the parking lot after this podcast and I see a grizzly
bear,
uh,
I can be afraid of it.
I can defend myself from it.
I can run from it.
I can shoot it.
If I have a gun,
I can,
I can decide to lock it up if,
if there's no place safe to put it.
You can do all of those things without attributing freewill to it.
I don't think a grizzly bear you can attribute,
no,
you can attribute no freewill to a 13 year old psychopath and still lock 'em up.
How does that change?
Life will change.
It will be in the case of a 13 year old.
We know that a 13 year old is not truly representative of who he's going to
become as a 40 year old.
And you can see,
you can,
you can change meant most 13 year olds that the book isn't written on their
life.
Uh,
that's not who everybody responsible for letting some 13 year olds is killed.
A bunch of people out on the street,
you'd see,
you know,
you put them back in some sort of an institution,
you train them for five years,
he goes out and kills again.
Are you responsible for that now?
Did you have the free will to decide to let this kid free?
We do a lot worse than that though.
We let,
we let people go who are obviously going to re-offend in the most shocking ways
and wait,
and we do it because we're making room for,
you know,
people are selling acid.
You get out of their dorm room.
I mean,
so it's like,
it's,
it's what,
right.
But that's a different argument,
isn't it?
I mean that's an argument of privatized prisons and financial systems that have
been cooptive by pharmaceutical companies and,
and special interest groups like prison guard lobbyists.
And there's,
so there's a lot more going on there.
I mean,
what is,
what's the,
what's the basis for decision making when it comes to keeping society safe?
It's,
it's all it's all about.
So this is another way to see the problem here.
Imagine we had a cure for psychopathy.
Imagine that we had a cure for evil.
So,
so we completely understand human evil,
the level of the brain turns out just by sheer luck,
it's just we get kind of one,
you know,
there's one neurotransmitter quite possible.
It's unlikely,
but it's possible.
Um,
and let's just say there's just one kind of one drug or a shot.
Give him a pill.
It's just a nutrient.
You know,
he was put it in the food supply,
right?
And we cure evil.
Now imagine to now we see we have this,
we have someone locked up.
It's Uday Hussein.
Or is this 13 year old who's done these evil things and we think,
you know what,
this guy was such an evil bastard,
we're going to withhold the cure from him as it just an extra punishment.
Right.
And that wouldn't make any sense.
Now that's the,
that would be like withholding surgery from Charles Whitman when you knew that
the brain tumor was the reason why he was going to be Charles Whitman.
Right?
So Charles Whitman,
you discover the brain tumor pressing on the Amygdala before he's going to go
out and kill every one.
And you say,
all right,
we're just going to solve the problem here.
Right?
So there'd be no ethical basis to before it though.
But PV,
but even after it.
But afterwards,
there's this concept of retribution where people want revenge.
The illusion debt.
Okay,
but that you wouldn't have that on the grizzly bear.
So say that's the different wood.
Well,
grizzly bear killed 30 people.
It'd be on a kilo would be different.
It would be,
didn't want to give them a pill to make them a happy grizzly bear.
No,
no.
But he's like,
I'm on some level,
you understand that a grizzly bear can't help it be a grizzly bear.
Yes.
And so it does actually,
people used to do this,
so there was this,
you could probably find this online.
There was a,
a circus elephant,
elephant,
and I'm in 1919 that ran a muck and killed a bunch of people.
And the townspeople people were so outraged and attributed so much evil to this,
this elephant that they hung it from a railroad crane.
I mean,
they lynched an elephant,
right?
And they felt they were very satisfied with themselves.
So this is,
you know,
justice.
But the reality is you have a mistreated circus element.
The elephant that went crazy and,
and,
and trampled some people.
Um,
and he was just being an elephant.
This is,
if we,
with someone like Charles Whitman,
and when you see that there's a brain tumor,
you recognize,
all right,
he's just being a guy who's got a brain tumor in the wrong place.
Right?
And,
and the,
and if we had a cure for it,
even after the fact,
that would be the appropriate thing to do.
If we had a cure for evil,
if we had a pill that just could make Uday Hussein a nice guy,
we would just give him the pill.
Right.
But then they're not responsible for their past actions cause they're a totally
different person.
Now they were seeing this pill.
Well yeah because Eh,
because evil is just a,
it's just the bad luck of having bad genes and bad neurochemistry.
That's a hard pill for people to swallow up there.
Their daughter was fed to the dogs of Uday Hussein.
That's a hard deal.
But he's not responsible in any way for his actions in the past because he had
some bad stuff going on in his child.
But then again,
look at his timeline.
He's not the three year old who has Saddam as a father isn't responsible.
Right.
So there's walking forward day by day,
month by month.
What can we just,
yeah,
exactly.
At what point his 18th birthday is that when you want to just bring down the
hammer on them?
It's an interesting question and I think it sort of highlights the great nature
of reality itself is that there's,
you know,
everybody wants everything to be black and white.
Yes and no plus and minus,
but it's not,
there's a lot of weird variables when it comes to being a human being.
And,
um,
I don't,
I see what you're saying,
but it's,
it's sort of a,
a weird argument because the pills don't exist.
The shot doesn't exist to turn someone from WHO's a psychopath into a good
person.
Well,
but that just proves,
it's just the point of concept that it makes.
It doesn't make sense to hold someone responsible for their jeans any more than
it does a brain tumor.
Uh,
and if you can't,
then,
but once you start taking,
taking each of these causal factors off the table of responsibility,
genes,
parents,
society,
environment,
cosmic rays,
there's nothing left.
And you can even take the sole off of it.
You know,
the soul,
you didn't pick your soul,
right?
Even if you think you have one,
you didn't make it.
And that's the problem.
And,
but again,
it doesn't change.
The important things that it doesn't change are things like self defense.
Yeah.
Esu.
You want to defend yourself against Uday Hussein.
You want to,
if,
if you don't have a cure for psychopathy,
you absolutely have to lock psychopaths up.
You can't let them run around harming people.
Um,
or psychopaths have a certain,
uh,
extremity.
Obviously there are a lot of psychopaths out who actually haven't harmed people.
They're just,
uh,
making inappropriate high eye contact.
Uh,
but the,
the difference is hatred and the kind of psychological suffering born of it
doesn't make a lot of sense and a clear path to solutions should they become
available,
opens up so that,
you know,
it's,
it's just like there's something.
So clarifying about the Charles Whitman Story.
Once you,
once you hear about the brain tumor,
you just think,
oh man,
all right,
well let's just,
you know,
it turns out this was not evil.
We're not talking about evil.
We're talking about a brain tumor.
Right?
Okay.
What I'm saying is the more we understand the human mind,
the level of the brain,
the more that feeling is going to encroach on all of these.
But do I know enough about the human brain to really make that determination?
Because when we're talking about where does a thought come from,
what,
you know,
what is going on inside your mind?
We can very crudely look at Fmr eyes and see areas of the brain that are
receiving activity,
but we don't necessarily know what is going on in slack.
Like creativity,
for example.
What makes a John Coltrane,
what makes of Richard Pryor?
I mean,
is it just the sum of their life experiences,
their genetics or expression or when,
when a thought comes to mind,
like,
okay,
put three,
in your case when you're writing and you're sitting in front of your computer
and you know,
I'm sure you probably have those moments where a concept or a sentence comes in,
it almost feels like it appears that at a midair,
right?
Everything appears that emitter,
that's the other thing is that,
I mean the other reason why I'm so committed to this is uh,
the subjective illusion,
the subjective side of the illusion can be cut through.
It's like a nick again,
most people starting point is we have this really robust feeling of freewill
and,
and self authorship and self creation and self determination and it's just as
hard to make it square with Charles Whitman and jeans and you know,
the rest of the neuro,
the neuro chemical story.
And um,
but I know I've got it.
You know,
by God I Know I've got this thing,
I can feel it right now that can be cut through.
You can actually feel it.
You can actually feel that when you say Chicago,
that is as that's like me saying Chicago.
It's like me saying,
okay,
he's going to say Chicago now.
Uh,
and you,
it just,
and it coming down to your mouth
consequences to these ideas.
Like picking a left hand,
the right hand picking Chicago,
it doesn't mean anything to me.
I,
well that's it.
That's just the simplest,
the simplest case that we can easily demonstrate.
But you can,
you can raise the stakes as much as you want,
but it means a lot.
If I decide to drive drunk,
it means a lot.
If,
I mean,
if you have let,
but arguably you have less control.
If I,
if I ask you,
you know,
you and I go out now and,
and,
uh,
have a few drinks and we're sitting around for a few hours wondering whether
our,
whether we're sober,
you're in a worse position to go to the talks kit.
Yeah.
It was like the way you look at that example then,
yeah,
about speeding.
What if I'm,
I'm at a red light and someone revs their car engine and Michael,
yeah,
bitch,
c'mon,
let's go and crash into someone.
But again,
you have more variables there that are driving you and influencing you and you,
and you feel like you're being led along,
around by the nose,
by the environment a little bit more there.
And this and this case is the,
I mean,
there's no stakes,
but this is as pure a moment of,
of agency as you're ever going to get.
When I say think now of a famous woman,
you're free to free to pick it.
Think of a bunch.
Right?
Okay.
And pick anyone you want just to,
and take as long as you want.
And just he just go back to the Lawrence.
Okay.
There you go.
Jennifer Lawrence.
Um,
I wonder why that is as pure.
That's gotta be as pure a demonstration of freedom of will as anything you're
going to get in life.
Now again,
nothing turns on it,
but that's,
that's pure and,
and less constrained by,
I don't know,
Shit.
Are you,
am I sober enough to drive or should I just speed or,
you know,
should I,
should I buy this thing or not?
Or am I going to have the doughnut?
And there's nothing like,
there's nothing riding on it.
So you were totally free.
Jesse.
You could have,
you had Jennifer Lawrence,
but then you had Oprah Winfrey and then you could have went back and say,
well then,
but what were you,
okay,
so where are you free to pick Oprah Winfrey?
You know who Oprah is?
Yeah.
Well Jennifer Lawrence is in the news.
It's one of the reasons why I picked it,
but that that's,
that's demonstrating a constraint that is driving you.
But I thought about Ann Wolfe first actually he was a boxer and I just decided
it's too obscure.
Right.
It would've been lost on me.
Yeah.
Um,
I just think that,
I agree with you without a doubt that there most certainly are a bunch of
factors involved in who a person is and many of them are outside of your
control.
But,
but when I asked you at missing,
the point you're missing here is that I'm not asking you,
I mean,
you can grant all of that,
the fact that they're those factors,
but what I'm saying is that you can subjectively experience the absence of free
will in that moment of picking Jennifer Lawrence.
You can,
you can subjectively no longer feel like,
like the problem of free will really goes away.
You no longer have this problem of,
I see what you're saying.
No,
I've got this thing and I can't figure out how to make it square with reality.
Jennifer Lawrence just comes out of the ether and the evil of the Internet.
Yeah.
And even if you deliberate,
she,
no matter how many times you go back and forth,
what the fact that you've set finally settle on her as opposed to somebody else
is inexplicably.
While I was trying to be funny,
that's why I went with her,
cause she's naked pictures of her all over the Internet today.
I don't know if you're aware.
I,
I have a loop.
I heard that somebody,
it was like some bunch of them,
some ice,
some apple hacking thing and the rally is not,
apparently it may be a,
that might be a factor,
but apparently people who have been collecting images off of people's computers
and because there's not just her,
it's,
it's a bunch of celebrities.
Bunch of celebrities.
Yeah.
I see what you're saying and I agree with you mostly.
Uh,
I don't disagree with you really.
I'm just sort of bouncing it around inside my head.
So when I,
when I say,
but what about this?
But what about that I'm doing that as much for myself as I am to to,
I'm not trying to disprove your point.
Um,
I think there's so many variables as to what makes a person to,
to tribute any,
anything to one thing,
whether it's discipline or whether it's a,
whether it's life experience,
whether it's what makes a man great,
what makes a woman fantastic,
what makes someone creative?
I don't know.
I think to boil it down to simply,
uh,
chemicals in the mind and neurosynapse is firing left or right.
I don't know.
I don't,
I think it's both.
I have a feeling that it's not just,
I don't think it's just determinism.
I think there's determinism,
but there's all this also mean you could,
your life changes based on whether or not eat a salad,
you need a sound or eat a bowl of pasta.
But I had a bowl of pasta.
You're just throwing in more neurochemistry there.
Yeah.
Without a doubt.
Yeah,
no doubt.
But what is the decision to eat that salad is the decision.
I decided today I want to be a healthier,
better person.
What's making me decide that this is just neurochemistry?
I mean,
is it just synapses is just my environment,
my life experiences.
If that's the case,
then the human beings are fucking robots where we will most certainly most of my
intention robot.
Yeah.
But that doesn't think it's,
that doesn't take out any of the good stuff of life.
So even if you,
from my point of view,
nothing important is lost here and something ethical is gained.
I mean,
so for instance,
that the possibility of having compassion for even,
even for evil people loving your enemy,
you know,
being like Jesus in that respect,
which makes absolutely no sense until you actually see a basis for having
compassion for someone like Uday Hussein.
Um,
I feel like that opens up based on this consideration,
but nothing else changes.
You know,
if Uday Hussein walked into the room,
you know,
I,
Eh,
I would put a bullet in him in self defense as quickly as the next guy.
I mean,
so it's just though that doesn't change,
but it's,
it is the difference between,
let me guess.
Someone like who Davis Jane is a malfunctioning robot.
You know,
he's a,
he's a grizzly bear.
So in that sense,
we really are just a product of our environments.
We are really are just numbers.
We really are just a sea of variables.
But we're also,
but we're,
we are consciousness subjectively speaking,
we are consciousness and its contents.
Now we know that there's a lot of unconscious massively affected by those Sia
variables and in fact cannot be detached from those Sia variables.
Yeah.
And yet it's as beautiful as you ever want it to be.
And it's a,
it's as profound as you want it to be.
It's not,
it doesn't become less profound.
And the spooky stuff that people want to introduce it doesn't actually amp up
the profundity.
It makes it,
it makes it less profound.
Well,
it actually makes us more responsible for engineering a healthy society because
we have to be aware of all the variables that are involved in every single human
beings developmental process.
And the more we can mitigate the negative ones,
the better we can make our society.
And that doesn't really discount the idea of people being responsible for their
actions or punishing people or
removing people.
Not at all.
We're saying it because punishment has its effects and,
but,
but now we're now we're free to see that.
We just want the punishments that have the effects we want.
We don't,
we can,
we can get rid of retribution and vengeance and we can just think,
okay,
what kind of world we want to live in.
And so maybe punishing people in certain ways,
um,
can be justified totally on pragmatic lines because it has a certain effect that
deter a certain crimes.
It makes them better people,
whatever it,
whatever those punishments are.
Let's say they,
they exist,
then you don't need us to a retributive story.
You just have a story of,
you know,
we want,
we want fewer car.
Jackings and we want the car jackers to be better people.
So we're going to do x,
Y,
andZ and,
and,
and deter carjacking on the one hand and rehabilitate carjacker car jackings and
carjackers on the other.
And another way that also highlights the really truly unethical practices of
privatized prisons,
uh,
of,
of things along those lines where you are purposely setting up laws in order to
victimize people to make it so that you know,
like you're playing a game,
you make it so that there,
there are pitfalls if they fall those pits.
Ooh Look,
I caught a beaver,
he fell into my trap.
And incentives are all wrong incentives.
That's one thing that uh,
I mean what you just said was,
was very important that seeing this co kind of web work
causality makes us more responsible for aligning society and all of its
incentives more wisely so as to make better people.
And I mean,
this I think is the biggest problem of our time are really anytime we have
systems where incentives are a poorly aligned,
where we,
where we were
even good people are attempted to be terrible because of the profit motive in
the system or because,
or they're very issue of our law itself.
Like when you have a prosecutor who's entire,
your,
your reputation is built on winning.
Yeah.
So it doesn't matter if he's innocent.
[inaudible] happened to win a massive amount of cases and a massive amount of
cases.
They're well aware that it's possible they could be wrong,
but their job is to prosecute.
The same can be said for a defense lawyer.
The defense lawyer could be aware that their client is probably lying,
but they must defend that client to the best of their ability,
including manipulating witnesses,
including the way they communicate with these witnesses to try to lead them down
certain paths to get him to say things that might be misconstrued by the jury.
All those things become more unethical if you look at the,
this concept of determinism.
Yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
Aligned incentives are,
are,
are huge.
And I mean that,
that one is
a,
is a classic case where what you'll get from defense attorneys is a very
strenuous defense of even the get,
you know that even the guilty need representation.
And I mean our adversarial system completely depends on my giving the best
possible defense of Jeffrey Dahmer.
I can,
even though I know that if I succeed and I sure hope I to succeed,
he's going to go off and cannibalize more people.
Um,
I think there's a pro ethical problem with that and,
and it,
but it's set up by the problem on the other side where you have a prosecutorial
system,
which is really not that concerned about send locking up an innocent person for
the rest of his life.
So it's a sense the system itself is so inherently flawed that it's all,
it almost would be tossed out and it should be where no one has an incentive,
whether then that person is guilty or innocent.
I mean that would be the most ethical way.
You just want to get to the truth and whatever,
whatever system is going to track the truth best.
I think this is the system we want them.
It's like you shouldn't be able to hire a Johnny Cochran.
You shouldn't be able to hire a Robert Shapiro.
They're too good at manipulating reality.
What you should do is you should have some sort of a system where you have
people that have no dog in the fight and these people have no,
there's no financial motive to make you guilty or innocent.
Like the idea of a jury system is also equally flawed because you're picking all
these people.
He sit down with them.
How do you feel about capital punishment?
How do you feel about birth control?
How do you feel about this?
That the other thing,
you know,
you ask him all these questions and then you pick the,
the,
the defense and the prosecution gets to pick,
you know,
from all these people based on their decisions with the idea being that this is
our likelihood for success.
If we go with these people and they have like a whole algorithm based on like
what answers they were there trying to get from these,
these various people.
That's a,
that's a really big hole in the system that's sort of highlighted by these
ideas.
This idea that someone has that you can benefit financially from some of being
innocent or guilty.
Yeah.
And if we had a,
a reliable lie detector,
this whole problem would go away.
Well,
will be eventually.
Maybe,
you know,
I know that,
uh,
I talked to you about this before.
One of your colleagues was on my Pamela everything.
I'm with Douglas.
Yeah.
With the FM Ri results of someone being arrested and prosecuted in India because
they had functional knowledge of a crime scene and well that was a troubling
case.
It seems premature,
you know,
we're,
we're running out of time here.
All right man.
Thank you very much.
Pleasure.
Bunch of people's minds and freaked a bunch of people out and I'm sure people
are going crazy writing blogs,
responding to comments all over the Internet and uh,
whoever that guy is that you had the issue with telling the fucking lighten up.
Sam Harris,
waking up a guide to spirituality and that spirituality should be in quotes,
put scare quotes on it without religion and it's available now.
I got a copy of it right here.
Is it on a audio book as well?
It's a,
it's available.
It's on sale next week or week early as an audio book to autumn.
Are you reading it?
Yes.
Oh Great.
Excellent.
I love that.
I don't like it when some act to read someone else's book,
but they do that a lot.
Some amazingly hard to do.
I don't know if you would be probably better at it than I am,
but I,
I found it incredibly hard to do.
It's really humbling to realize that people do this professionally with other
people's books.
I mean,
it's,
it's amazing.
What was hard about it?
It's just I,
you know,
I,
I find that I inadvertently have written tongue twisters into my pro there.
There were a few sentences.
I literally had to change words because I couldn't get through them.
It was like a Cirque de Solei act that I couldn't perform really just to read
the sentence.
Well that's interesting because yeah,
when you read something and it's in your mind,
you have your mouth closed.
You're not making any noises.
It's easy.
You put something in there with it.
It's got the consonants in the wrong place.
And I,
there was one time,
it was like 20 takes and you've got people in,
you know,
you're in a booth and you got to be a producer and a and an engineer or
listening to you and it's just all right.
We're,
I'm going to rewrite this sentence.
Sorry guys.
All right.
Uh,
the book,
Sam Harris,
waking up.
Um,
thanks.
Thank you very much man.
Thanks to our sponsor.
Thanks to Squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com enter the code word Joe and get 10% off your first
purchase.
Thanks to legal zoom.
Go to legal zoom.com.
Use The code word Rogan at referral,
uh,
in the referral box at checkout for savings.
And thanks on it.com o n n.
I t used Codeword Rogan.
Save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
we'll be back tomorrow with dom.
I rarer and then again on Thursday with Joe Derosa.
See you soon.
Bye.
[inaudible] mom.
Yeah.